hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor at exam pro and i'm bringing
you another complete study course and
this time it's the azure ai fundamentals
made available here on free codecamp so
this course is designed to help you pass
the exam and achieve microsoft issued
certification
and we're going to do that by providing
you great lecture content
follow alongs to get that hands-on
experience and cheat sheets for the day
of your exam
so when you do get that certification
you can put it on your resume or
linkedin
and show that you have that azure a
knowledge to get that cloud job
or get that promotion so i want to
introduce myself i'm previously the cto
of multiple ed tech companies
with 15 years uh industry experience
five years specializing cloud
i'm an abs community hero and i've
published many free cloud courses
i love star trek and coconut water so i
just want to take a moment here to thank
viewers like you because it's you that
make these free courses possible
and if you want to support more free
courses just like this one
a great way to do that is buying our
additional study
materials on exam pro dot co and for
this exam it's forward slash ai 900
this will get you access to study notes
flash cards quizlets
downloadable cheat sheets and practice
exams and you'll also be able to ask
questions and get some
learning support so if you want to keep
up to date with any of the more courses
i am releasing
you can follow me on twitter at andrew
at andrew brown
and share with me when you pass exam or
what you might like to see
as the next course so there we go let's
get to it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
here learning about the ai 900 asking
the most important question which is
what is
the a900 so the azure ai fundamental
certification is for those seeking an ml
role such as ai engineer or data
scientist
and the certification will demonstrate a
person can define and understand
azure cognitive services ai concepts
knowledge mining
responsible ai basis of ml pipelines
classical ml models
automl and azure ml studio so you don't
need to know
super complicated uh ml knowledge here
but definitely helps to get you through
there but yeah
so this certification is generally
referred to by its course code the ai
900 and it's the natural path
for the azure ai engineer or azure data
scientist certification
and this generally is an easy course to
pass it's great for those new to cloud
or ml related technology looking at our
road map
you might be asking okay well what are
the paths and what should i learn
and so here are my markers and let's get
out the annotation tool or laser pointer
to see where we can go now if you
already have your az-900
uh that's a great starting point before
you take your ai 900
if you don't have your az-900 you can
jump right into the a900 but i strongly
recommend you go get that a900 because
it gives you
general uh general foundational
knowledge it's just another
thing that you should not have to worry
about which is just how to use azure at
a fundamental level
uh do you need the dp900 to take the
ai-900
no but a lot of people seem to like to
go this route where they want to have
that data foundation
before they move on to a uh to the ai
900 because they know that that
is just broad knowledge is going to be
useful there uh so
you know it is a pairing that you see a
lot of people getting the ai 900 and the
dpi
900 together for the a900 the path is a
little bit more clear it's either going
to be data scientist or ai engineer
so ai engineer is just the cognitive
services turned up to 11.
you have to know how to use the ai
services in and out
for data scientists it's more focused on
setting up actual pipelines
and things like that within the azure
machine learning studio so you just have
to decide which path is for you
the data scientist is definitely harder
than the ai engineer i think the code
just was updated so i just updated that
to 102
and i think the ai engineers to be two
separate uh you had to take two separate
um
courses but now it's just a single one
so it's unified
uh but you know if you aren't ready for
the data sciences some people like
taking the ai engineer first
and then doing the data scientists so
this is kind of like a warm up again
it's not
a hundred percent necessary but it's
just uh based on your personal
uh learning style and a lot of times
people like to take the data engineer
after the data scientists just to round
out their complete knowledge
now if you already have the az900 and
the associate
you can safely go to the data scientist
if you want to risk it
um because this one is really hard so if
you've passed the az-104
uh you know you're gonna probably have a
lot more confidence learning up about
this stuff
all this fun foundational stuff at this
level here but of course it's always
recommended to go grab these
foundational certs because sometimes
course materials just do not cover the
information
and so the obvious stuff is going to get
left out okay
so moving forward here so how long
should you study to pass for the ai 900
well if you have one year's experience
with azure you're looking at five hours
as little as five hours could be up to
ten hours if you have passed the az 900
to dp900 around 10 hours is the average
if you're completely new to mlai you're
looking at 15 hours
this could get extended to 20 to 30
hours again it just depends on how green
you are like how new you are to these
concepts
but you know i think on average we're
looking at 15 hours the recommended
study time is 30 minutes
a day for 14 days should get you through
it um
you know but you know just don't over
study and just don't spend too little
time you know
so where do you take this exam well you
can take it in person at a test center
or online from the convenience of your
own home
so there's two popular test centers
there's psi and pearson vue
well and i should say these are uh um
there's
these are not necessarily test centers
and per se but they are
a collection of test centers that are
partnered with psi pearson view so that
you can easily take it at a local
test center if you ever heard the term
proctored that is that means a
supervisor a person that is monitoring
you while you're taking the exam term
when we talk about online exams they'll
say proctored exams to refer to the
online component
if i had the option between in person
online always the in person because
it's a controlled environment it's way
less stress uh
stress uh stressful uh and um you know
online there can so many things can go
wrong so you know but it's up to your
personal preference and your situation
okay
what does it take to pass the exam well
you got to watch the lectures
and memorize key information do hands-on
labs and follow along with your own
azure account
i would say that you could probably get
away with just watching all the videos
in this one without having to do
uh but again you know it really does
reinforce that information if you do
take the time there
there is some stuff that is in azure
machine learning studio you might be
wary of
launching because we do have to run
instances and they will cost
money so if you if you feel that you're
not comfortable with that just watching
you should be okay
but when you get into the associate tier
you absolutely you just have to expect
to pay something to
to learn and take that risk okay you
want to do paid online practice exams
that simulate the real exam
uh so i do have paid practice exams uh
that accompany uh this course that are
on my platform exam pro
and that's how you can help support more
of these free courses
can you pass this without taking
practice exam azure's a little bit
harder if this is an aws
um exam i would say yes for azure
it's kind of risky the asian 100 sure ai
900 dp900 sc900
no i think you should get a practice
exam at least one
uh or or go through the sample one
there's a sample one uh probably
around four on the azure website let's
just look at the
exam guide breakdown here very shortly
and then in the following video we'll
look at in more detail so
it's broken down into the following
domain so describe ai workloads and
considerations describe fundamental
principles of machine learning on azure
describe
features of computer vision workloads
and azure describe features of natural
language processing workloads on azure
describe features of conversational ai
workloads on azure and i want you to
notice
it says describe describe describe
describe describe that's good
because that tells you it's not going to
be super super hard
right um if you start seeing things that
say beyond describe and identify then
you know it's going to be a bit harder
okay the passing grade here is uh
700 out of a thousand so that's around
70 uh 70 percent i would say around
because you could possibly fail with 70
percent
because these things work on scaled
scoring for response types there's about
40 to 60 questions and you can afford to
get
uh 12 to 18 questions wrong i put an
asterisk there because
there's not always just one question uh
um per
uh like per section but i'll talk about
it here in a second so some questions
are worth more than one point
there's no penalty for wrong questions
some questions cannot be skipped
and the format of questions can be
multiple choice multiple answer
drag and drop hot area case studies case
studies i don't remember
i don't think i saw a case study on mine
but case studies will have a series of
questions
um a series of questions that make up or
come back to a particular business
problem so those are
are very interesting that's why we have
that asterisk up here okay
so for the duration you get one hour
that means about one minute per question
the time for this exam is 16 minutes
your seat time is 90 minutes seat time
refers to the amount
of time that you should take to allocate
for that exam so this includes time to
review the instructions read accept the
nda
complete the exam and provide feedback
at the end exam this is going to be
valid for 24 months up to two years
before we do certification
and uh you know we'll proceed to the
full exam guide now okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what we've pulled up here is the
official exam
outline on the microsoft website if you
want to find this yourself just got to
type in
ai900 azure or microsoft you should be
able
to easily find it the page looks like
this and what i want you to do is scroll
on down because we're looking for skills
measured and from there we're going to
download the skills outline
and once we have that open you might
want to bump up the text
and so what you'll always see at these
documents is a red text at the top
saying hey we've updated the track
azure loves updating their courses with
minute updates that don't generally
affect the
outcome of the study here but it does
get a lot of people worry because they
always say well is your course out of
date i said no no
they're just making minor changes
because they'll do this like five times
a year
and so if there was a major revision
what would happen is they would change
it so
instead of being the ai 900 it'd be like
the ai
901 or 902. we saw that recently with
the
um the ai 100 where it's now the ai
ai 102 or 103 sorry
so you know just watch out for those and
if it's a major revision then yes the
course
you would need a completely new course
um and it would not match but for minors
it's going to be my new thing so if we
scroll on down and a lot of times
they'll just cross out what they've
changed and this one in particular
they did not show us in detail you'd
have to read through the comparison
but we'll look at the new listing here
and work our way through here so
describe artificial or ai workloads and
considerations
so here we're just kind of describing
the generalities of
ai so prediction forecasting this is
because when we use automl
prediction would be classification and
regression and forecasting would be that
real time series forecasting i suppose
identity features anomaly detection so
not a lot in the
exam for this so we we touch on it
briefly computer vision workloads
there's a lot of stuff
under computer vision as you'll find it
through the course
nlp and knowledge mining workloads
conversational ai workloads and again
these are all the concepts not how to
use the services
then you have the responsible eye
section and so microsoft has these
six principles that they really want you
to know and they push it through
all their ai services so those are the
six you'll need to know they're not that
hard to learn
um then describe fundamental principles
of machine learning on azure
uh so here it's just describing
regression classification and
clustering we have a lot of practical uh
experience with these
in the course so you will understand at
the end what these are used for
for core machine learning concepts we
can identify features and labels in a
data set so that's the data labeling
service
describe how training validation data
sets are used in machine learning so we
touch on that
describe how machine learning algorithms
are used for training select and
interpret model evaluations and metrics
for classification regression
a lot of these you'll encounter these in
auto ml because it automatically does it
but we can see how it uh
does that okay without having to do it
ourselves
identify core tasks and creating a
machine learning solution so describe
common features of data ingestion
preparation
feature engineering selection uh
features of model training evaluation
features of model deployment and
management and then
we have described no code solutions so
auto ml they like to call it automated
ml but really the industry just calls it
automl
then there's the designer for building
out pipelines
here is where we see some changes so
identify features of image
classification
uh features of object detection
solutions so semantic segmentation
is gone which is great because i don't
even know what that is
uh so it's great that it's out of there
ocr solutions and then you have
face detection then under computer
vision tasks we have computer vision
custom vision face services form
recognizer told you there's a lot around
computer vision
fit nlp we have key phrase extraction
identity recognition sentiment analysis
language modeling
speech recognition uh synthesis this one
doesn't really appear much
uh it's kind of a concept not so much
something we have to do
then there's translation we have nlp
more nlp stuff so text analytics
uh luis or lewis i'm not sure which way
to pronounce it speech service and text
translator text then down below
below we have a conversational eye so
building out web
chat bots uh and uh
characters of conversation ai solutions
looks like they used to have telephone
and personal digital assistants not sure
why they decided to remove that but
i that's okay i think that's fine q a
maker and
azure bot i really like this service by
the way so yeah there we go that is the
outline and now we'll jump into the
actual course
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the layers of
machine learning so
here i have this thing that looks like
kind of an onion and what it is it's
just describing the
relationship between these uh ml terms
uh
related to ai and we'll just work our
way through here starting at the top so
artificial intelligence also known as ai
is when machines that perform
jobs that mimic human behavior so it
doesn't describe uh
how it does that but it's just the fact
that that's what ai is
uh one layer underneath we have machine
learning so machines that get better at
a task without explicit programming
uh then we have deep learning so these
are machines that have an artificial
neural network inspired by the human
brain to solve complex problems
and if you're talking about someone that
actually assembles either ml or
or deep learning models or algorithms
that's a data scientist so a person with
multi-disciplinary skills and math
statistics predictive modeling machine
learning to make future predictions
so what you need to understand is that
ai is just the outcome
right and so ai could be using ml
underneath or
deep learning or a combination of both
or just if else statements okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
the key elements of ai so ai is the
software that imitates human behaviors
and capabilities and there are key
elements according to azure or microsoft
as to what makes up a.i so let's go
through this list quickly here so we
have machine learning which is the
foundation of an ai system
that can learn and predict like a human
you have anomaly detection so detect
outliers or things out of place
like a human computer vision be able to
see like a human
natural language processing also known
as nlp be able to process human
languages and refer context
you know like a human uh conversational
ai be able to hold a conversation
with a human so you know i wrote here
according to microsoft and azure because
you know the
the global definition is a bit different
but i just wanted to put this here
because i've definitely seen this as an
exam question and so
we're gonna have to go with azure's
definition here okay
let's define what is a data set so a
data set is a logical grouping of units
of data that are closely related to
or share the same data structure and
there are publicly available data sets
that are used in learning of statistics
data
analytics and machine learning i just
want to cover a couple here so the first
is the mnist database so images of
handwritten digits used to test classify
cluster image processing algorithms
commonly used when learning
how to build computer vision ml models
to translate handwritten
into or handwriting into digital text so
it's just a bunch of
handwritten uh numbers and letters and
then another
very popular data set is the common
objects in context cocoa coco dataset
so this is a data set which contains
many common images using a json file
cocoa format that identify objects or
segments within an image
and so this dataset has a lot of stuff
in it so object segmentations
reconnection in ip context
super pixel stuff segmentation they have
a lot of images
and a lot of objects so there's a lot of
stuff in there so
why am i talking about this and in
particular coco data sets well
when you use azure machine learning
studio it has a
data labeling service and um
the thing is is that it can actually
export out into cocoa formats that's why
i wanted to get exposure to what coco
was
and the other thing is is that when
you're building out azure machine
learning uh
pipelines you they actually have open
data sets which you'll see later in the
course
um that shows you that you can just use
very common ones and so
uh you might see mnist and uh the other
one there
so i just wanted to get you some
exposure okay
[Music]
let's talk about data labeling so this
is the process of identifying
raw data so images text files videos and
adding one or more
meaningful and informative labels to
provide context so a machine learning
model can learn so with supervised
machine learning
labeling is a prerequisite to produce
training data and each piece of data
will generally be labeled by a human
the reason why i say generally here is
because with azure's
data labeling service they can actually
do ml assisted labeling
so with unsupervised machine learning
labels will be produced by
the machine and may not be human
readable
and then one other thing i want to touch
on is the term called ground truth so
this is a proper a properly labeled data
set
that you can use as the objective
standard to train and assess a given
model
is often called ground truth the
accuracy of your train model will depend
on the accuracy of your ground truth
now using azure's tools i never see them
to use the word ground truth i see that
a lot in aws
and even this graphic here is from aws
but
i just want to make sure you are
familiar with all that stuff okay
[Music]
let's compare supervise unsupervised and
reinforcement learning starting at the
top we got supervised learning this is
where the data
has been labeled for training and it's
considered task driven because you are
trying to make a prediction get a value
back so
when the labels are known and you want a
precise outcome when you need a specific
value returned
and so you're going to be using
classification and regression in these
cases
for unsupervised learning this is where
data that has not been labeled
the ml model needs to do its own
labeling this is considered data driven
it's trying to recognize a structure
or a pattern and so this is when the
labels are not known and the outcome
does not need to be precise
when you're trying to make sense of data
so you have clustering
dimensionality reduction and association
if you've never heard this term before
the idea is it's trying to reduce the
amount of dimensions to make it easier
to work with the data
so make sense of the data right we have
reinforcement learning
so this is where there is no data
there's an environment and an ml model
generates data
and makes many attempts to reach a goal
so this is considered uh decisions
driven
and so this is for game ai learning
tasks robot navigation when you've seen
someone code a video game that can play
itself that's what this is
if you're wondering this is not all the
types of machine learning uh and these
are
specific unsupervised and supervised is
considered classical machine learning
because they have a heavily
rely on statistics and math to produce
the outcome
but there you go
so what is a neural network well it's
often described as mimicking the brain
it's a neuron or node that represents an
algorithm so data is inputted into a
neuron and based on the output the data
will be passed to
one of many connected neurals the
connections between
neurons is weighted i really should have
highlighted that one that's very
important
uh the network is organized into layers
there will be an input layer
uh one to many hidden layers and an
output layer so here's an example of a
very simple neural network
notice the nn a lot of times you'll see
this in ml as an abbreviation for neural
networks
and sometimes neural networks are just
called neural nets so just understand
that's the same term here
what is deep learning this is a neural
network that has three or more hidden
layers it's considered deep learning
because at this point it's
uh it's not human readable to understand
what's going on with it within those
layers
what is forward feed so neural networks
uh where they have connections between
nodes that do not form a cycle they
always move forward so that just
describes
a a forward pass through the network
you'll see fn which stands for forward
feed neural network
just describe that type of network then
there's
back propagation which are in forward
feed networks
this is where we move backwards through
the neural net adjusting the weights to
improve the outcome on next iteration
this is how a neural net learns
the way the back propagation knows to do
this is that there's a loss function so
a function that compares
the ground truth to the prediction to
determine the error rate how bad the
network performs so when it gets to the
end
it's going to perform that calculation
and then it's going to do its back
propagation and just the weights
then you have activation functions i'm
just going to clear this up here
so activation functions
they're an algorithm applied to a hidden
layer uh node that affects connected
output so
for this entire hidden layer they'll all
have the same uh one here and it just
kind of affects
uh how it learns and like how the
weighting works so it's part of back
propagation and just
the learning process there's a concept
of dense so when the next layer
increases the amount of nodes
and you have sparse so when the next
layer decreases the amount of notes
anytime you see something going from a
dense layer to a sparse layer that's
usually
called dimensional dimensionality
reduction because you're reducing the
amount of dimensions because the amount
of
nodes in your network determines the
dimensions you have
okay
[Music]
what is a gpu well it's a general
processing unit that is specially
designed to quickly
render high-resolution images and videos
concurrently gpus can perform
parallel operations on multiple sets of
data so they are commonly used for
non-graphical tasks such as machine
learning
and scientific computation so a cpu has
an average of 4 to 16 processor cores
a gpu can have thousands of processor
cores so something that has 48 gpus
could have as many as 40
000 cores here's an image i grabbed
right off the nvidia website
and so it really illustrates very well
like
how this would be really good for
machine learning or
neural networks because neural networks
have a bunch of nodes they're very
repetitive tasks
if you can spread them across a lot of
cores that's going to work out really
great
so gpus are suited for repetitive and
highly parallel computing tasks such as
rendering
graphics cryptocurrency mining deep
learning and machine learning
[Music]
we're talking about cuda before we can
let's talk about what nvidia is so
nvidia is a company that manufactures
graphical process units for gaming and
professional markets if you play video
games you've heard of nvidia so what is
cuda
it is the compute unified device
architecture it is a parallel
computing platform and api by nvidia
that allows developers to use cuda
enabled gpus
for general purpose computing on gpus so
gpgus
all major deep learning frameworks are
integrated with nvidia deep
learning sdk the nvidia deep learning
sdk is a collection of nvidia libraries
for deep learning
one of those libraries is the cuda deep
neural network library so c-u-d-n-n
so cuda or c-u-d-n-n provides highly
tuned implementations for standard
routines such as
forward and back convolution convolution
is really great for
computer vision pooling normalization
activation layers
uh so you know in the azure
certification
uh for the ai 900 they're not going to
be talking about cuda but if you
understand these two things you'll
understand why gpus
really matter okay
[Music]
all right let's get a easy introduction
into machine learning pipeline
so this one is definitely not an
exhaustive one and we're definitely
going to see
more complex ones uh throughout this
course but let's get to it here so
starting on the left-hand side we might
start with data labeling
this is very important when you're doing
supervised learning because you need to
label your data so the ml model can
learn by example during training
this stage and the future engineering
stage
is considered pre-processing because we
are preparing our data
to be trained for the model when we move
on to feature engineering the idea here
is that ml models can only work with
numerical data
so you'll need to translate it into a
format that it can understand so extract
out the important data
that the ml model needs to focus on
okay then there's the training steps so
your model needs to learn how to become
smarter it will perform multiple
iterations getting smarter with each
iteration
uh you might also have a hyperparameter
tuning
uh step here says tuning but should say
tuning
but the ml model can have different
parameters so you can use ml
to try out many different parameters to
optimize the outcome
when you get to deep learning it's
impossible to tweak
the parameters by hand so you have to
use hyper parameter
tuning then you have serving sometimes
known as deploying
uh but you know when we say deploy we
talk about the entire pipeline not
necessarily just the
ml model step so we need to make an ml
model accessible so we
serve it by hosting in a virtual machine
or container
when we're talking about azure machine
learning it's either going to be an
azure kubernetes service or azure
container instance
and you have uh inference so inference
is the active request
of requesting to make a prediction so
you send your payload with either csv or
whatever and
you get back the results you have a real
time endpoint and batch processing so
real time is just
there they can batch can be real time as
well but generally it's slower
but the idea is that do i am i making a
single item prediction or am i giving
you a bunch of data at once
and again this is a very simplified ml
pipeline i'm sure we'll revisit
ml pipeline later in this course
[Music]
so let's compare the uh the terms
forecasting and prediction so
forecasting you make a prediction with
relevant data
it's great for analysis of trends and
it's not
guessing and when you're talking about
prediction this is where you make a
prediction without relevant data you use
statistics to predict future outcomes
it's more of guessing and it uses
decision theory
so imagine you have a bunch of data and
the idea is you're going to infer from
that data
okay maybe it's a maybe it's b maybe
it's c and for prediction
you don't have really much data so
you're going to have to
uh kind of invent it and the idea is
that you'll figure out what the outcome
is there
these are extremely broad terms but you
know just so you have
a high level view of these two things
okay
so what are performance or evaluation
metrics well they are used to evaluate
different machine learning algorithms
the idea is uh you know when your
machine learning makes a prediction
these are the metrics you're using to
evaluate to determine you know is your
ml model working as you
intended so for different types of
problems different metrics
matter this is absolutely not an
exhaustive list i just
want you to get you exposure to these uh
words and things
so that when you see them you go okay
i'll come back here and refer to this
but lots of these you're just it's not
it's not necessarily remember but
classification metrics you should know
so classification we have accuracy
precision recall f1 score
rock and auc for regression metrics we
have msc
ce mae ranking metrics we have mmr dcg
ndcg statistical metrics we have
correlation
computer vision metrics we have psnr
ssim
iou nlp metrics we have perplexity blue
meteor rogue
deep learning related metrics we have
inception score i cannot say this
person's name but
or i'm assuming it's a person but this
inception distance
and there are two categories of
evaluation metrics we have internal
evaluation so metrics used to evaluate
the internals of an ml model so accuracy
f1 score precision recall i call them
the famous four
used in all kinds of models and
external evaluation metrics used to
evaluate the final prediction of an
ml model so yeah don't get too
worked up here i know it's a lot of
stuff the ones that matter we will
see again okay
[Music]
well let's take a look at jupiter
notebooks so these are web-based
applications for authoring documents
that combine live code narrative text
equations visualizations so if you're
doing data science or you're building ml
models you apps are going to be working
with jupiter notebooks they're always
integrated into
cloud service providers ml tools
so jupyter notebook actually came about
from ipython so ipython is the precursor
of it and they extracted that feature
out it became jupyter notebook
ipython is now a kernel to run
python so when you execute out python
code here
it's using ipython which is just a
version of python jupyter notebooks
were overhauled and better integrated
into an ide called jupiter labs which
we'll talk about here in a moment
and you generally want to open notebooks
and labs the legacy web-based interface
is known as jupiter classic notebooks
so this is what the old one looks like
you can still open them up but everyone
uses jupiter labs now okay so let's talk
about jupiter labs
jupiter labs is the next generation
web-based user interface all
familiar features of the classic jupiter
notebook is in a flexible powerful user
interface
it has notebooks a terminal a text
editor a file browser
rich outputs jupyter labs will
eventually replace the classic
jupyter notebooks so there you go
we keep mentioning regression but let's
talk about it in uh more detail here so
we kind of understand the concept so
regression is the process of finding a
function
to record a labeled data set notice it
says labeled that means it's going to be
for supervised learning
into a continuous variable number so
another way to say it is predict this
variable in the future so the future is
just means like that continuous variable
it doesn't have to be time but that's
just a good example of regression
so what will the temperature be next
week so
will it be 20 celsius how would we
determine that well we would have
vectors so
dots that are plotted on a graph that
has multiple dimensions
the dimensions could be greater than
just x and y you could have many
and then you have a regression line this
is the line that's going through our
data set
and and that's going to help us figure
out
how to predict the value so how would we
do that well we need to calculate the
distance of a vector
from the regression line which is called
an error and so different regression
algorithms use
the error to predict different variable
future variables so just to look at this
graphic here so here's our regression
line
and here is a a dot like a vector a
piece of information
and this distance from the line the the
the actual distance is what we're going
to use in our ml model to figure out
if we were to plot another line up here
right
you know we would compare this line to
all the other lines okay and
that's how we'd find similarity and what
we'll commonly see for this
is mean squared error root mean squared
error
mean absolute error so msc mrsc and mae
okay
[Music]
let's take a closer look at the concepts
of classification so classification is
the process of finding a function to
divide a
labeled data set so again this is
supervised learning
into classes or categories so predict a
category to apply to the inputted data
so
will it rain next saturday will it be
sunny or rainy so we have our data set
and the idea is we're drawing through
this a classification line to divide the
data set
so regression we're measuring the line
two are the the vectors to the line
and this one is just what side of the
line is it on if it's on this side then
it's sunny if it's on this side
it's rainy okay for classification
algorithms we got
logistic regression decision trees
random force neural networks
naive bayes k nearest neighbor also
known as k
n n and support vector machines svms
okay
[Music]
let's take a closer look at clustering
so clustering is the process of
grouping unlabeled data so unlabeled
data means it's unsupervised learning
based on similarities and differences so
the outcome could be group data based on
similarities or differences
i guess it's the same description up
here but imagine we have a graph and we
have data and the idea is we draw
boundaries around that to see
similar groups so maybe we're
recommending purchases to windows
computers
or recommending purchases to mac
computers now remember this is unlabeled
data
so the label is being inferred or um
or they're just saying these things are
similar right so clustering algorithms
we got k-means
k-meadoids a density base hierarchical
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the confusing
matrix and this is a table to visualize
the model predictions the predicted
versus the ground truth labels the
actual
also known as an air matrix and they are
useful for classification
problems to determine if our if our
classification
is working as we think it is so imagine
we have a question how many bananas
did this person eat or these people eat
and so we have this kind of uh
box here where we have predicted versus
actual and it's really
comparing the ground truth and what the
model predicted right
and so on the exam they'll ask you
questions like
okay well imagine that uh and they might
not even say yes or no maybe like zero
and one
and so what they're saying is you know
imagine
you have you want to tell us the true
positives right and so the idea is they
won't show you the labels here but you
know
one and one would be a true positive and
zero and zero would be a false
negative okay another thing they'll ask
you about these uh confusion matrixes
is uh the size of them so the idea is
that we're looking right now
at a um oops just gonna erase that there
but we are looking at a binary
classifier because we have
one label and uh uh just two labels
right
one and two okay but you could have
three say one two and three so how would
you calculate that well there would just
be a third cell over here
uh you know and it's going to be actual
and predicted because we're only going
to have ground truth
versus prediction and so that's how
you'll know it will be six
the size will be six might not say cells
but we'll just say six okay
[Music]
so to understand anomaly detection let's
define quickly what is an anomaly so an
abnormal thing
that is marked by deviation from the
norm or standard so
anomaly detection is the process of
finding outliers within a data set
called anomaly so detecting when a piece
of data or access patterns
appear suspicious or malicious so
use cases for nominal detection can be
data cleaning intrusion detection
fraud detection system health monitoring
event detection and sensory or sensor
networks
ecosystem disturbances detection of
critical and cascading flaws
anomaly detections by hand is a very
tedious process so using ml for anomaly
detection is more efficient and accurate
and azure has a service called anomaly
detector detects anomalies and data
to quickly find quickly identify and
troubleshoot issues
[Music]
so computer vision is when we use
machine learning neural networks to gain
high level understanding of digital
images or videos so
for computer vision deep learning
algorithms we have convolutional neural
networks
these are for image and video
recognition they're inspired after how
the human eye actually processes
information and sends it back to the
brain to be processed you have recurrent
neural networks rnns
which are generally used for handwriting
recognition or speech recognition of
course these algorithms have other
applications but these are the most
common use cases for them for types of
computer vision
we have image classification so look at
an image or video and classify its place
in a category object detection so
identify objects within an image or
video and apply
labels and location boundaries semantic
segmentation so identify segments or
objects by drawing pixel masks around
them so great for objects and movement
image analysis so analyze an image
or video to apply descriptive context uh
labels so maybe an employee is sitting
at a desk in tokyo would be
something that image analysis would do
optical character recognition
or cocr find text in images or videos
and extract them
into digital text for editing facial
detection so detect faces in a photo
or video and draw a location boundary
and label their expression so for
computer vision
to some things around azure or microsoft
services there's one called seeing ai
it's an ai app developed by microsoft
for ios
and so you use your device camera to
identify obj people and objects and the
app is audibly describes those
objects for people with visual
impairments it's totally free if you
have an ios app
i have an android phone so i cannot use
it but here it's great some of the azure
computer vision service offerings is
computer vision so analyze images and
videos
extract descriptions tags objects and
text custom vision so
custom image classification object
detection models using
your own images face so detect and
identify people
and emotions and images form recognizers
so
translate scan documents into key value
or tabular
editable data
[Music]
so natural language processing also
known as nlp
is machine learning that can understand
the context of a corpus
corpus being a body of related text so
nlps enable you to analyze and interpret
text within documents and email messages
interpret or contextualize spoken tokens
so for example maybe customer sentiment
analysis whether customers happy or sad
synthesized speech so a voice assistance
assistant talking to you
automatically translates spoken or
written phrases and sentences between
languages
interprets broken or written commands
and determine appropriate actions
a very famous example for a voice
assistant specifically or virtual
assistant
for microsoft is cortana it uses the
bing search engine to perform tasks such
as setting reminders and answering
questions for the user
and if you're on a windows 10 machine
it's very easy to activate cortana by
accident
when we were talking about azure's mlp
offering we have text
and analytics so sentiment analysis to
find out what customers think
find topic topic relevant phrases using
key phrase extraction identify the
language of the text with language
detection
detect and categorize entities in your
text with named entity recognition for
translator we have real-time text
translation multi-language support
for speech service we have transcribe
audible speech into readable
searchable texts and then we have
language understand
understanding also known as lewis
natural language processing service that
enables you to understand human language
in your own application website
chatbots iot device and more when we
talk about conversational ai
it usually generally uses nlp so that's
where you'll see that overlap next okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at conversational
ai which is technology that can
participate in conversations with humans
so we have chat bots voice assistants
and interactive voice recognition
systems which is like
the second version to interactive voice
response system so you know when you
call in
and they say press these numbers that is
a response system and a recognition
system is when they can actually
take human uh speech and translate that
into action so the use cases here would
be online customer support
replaces human agents for uh for
replying about customer
faqs maybe shipping questions anything
about customer support
accessibility so voice operator ui for
those who are visually impaired
hr processes so employee training
onboarding updating employee information
i've never seen it used like that but
that's what they say as a use case
healthcare accessible affordable
healthcare
so maybe you're doing a claim process
i've never seen this but maybe in the
u.s where you do more your claims and
everything is privatized it makes more
sense
internet of things so iot devices so
amazon alexa apple siri google home
and i suppose cortana but it doesn't
really have a particular device so
that's why i didn't list it there
computer software so autocomplete search
on phone or desktop so that would be
cortana something it could do uh for the
two services that are around
conversational ai
for azure we have q a maker so create a
conversational question and answer bot
from your existing
content also known as a knowledge base
and azure bot service intelligent
serverless
bot service that scales on demand used
for creating publishing managing bots so
uh the idea is you make your bot here
and then you deploy it with this okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at responsible ai
which focuses on ethical transparent and
accountable uses of ai technology
microsoft puts into practice responsibly
via its six
microsoft ai principles this whole thing
is invented by microsoft
and so you know it's not necessarily a
standard but it's something that
microsoft is pushing hard to have people
adopt okay
so with the first thing we have is
fairness so this is an ai system which
should treat
all people fairly we have reliability
and safety and ai systems should perform
reliably
and safely privacy and security ai
systems should be secure
and respect privacy inclusiveness system
should
empower everyone and engage people
transparency ai systems should be
understandable accountability
people should be accountable for ai
systems and we need to know these in
greater detail so we're going to have a
short little video on each of these okay
[Music]
the first on our list is fairness so ai
systems should treat
all people fairly so an ai system can
reinforce existing social
societal stereo stereotypical bias
can be introduced uh during the
development of a pipeline so
any systems that are used to allocate or
withhold opportunities resources or
information
in domains such as criminal justice
employee employment and hiring finance
and credit
so an example here would be an ml model
designed to select a final applicant for
hiring pipeline without incorporating
any bias based on gender ethnicity or
may result in unfair advantage
so azure ml can tell you how each
feature can influence a model's
prediction for bias
one thing that could be of use is fair
learn so it's an open source python
project to help data scientists to
improve fairness in the ai systems
at the time of i made this course a lot
of their stuff is
still in preview so you know it's the
fairness component it's not 100 there
but it's great to see that they're
getting that along okay
[Music]
so we are on to our second ai principle
for microsoft and this one is ai systems
should perform reliably and safely so ai
software must be rigorously tested to
ensure they work as expected before
release to the end user
if there are scenarios where ai is
making mistakes it is important to
release a report
quantified risks and harms to end users
so they are informed of the shortcomings
of an ai solution something you should
really remember for the exam
they'll definitely ask that ai where
concern
for reliability safety for humans is
critically important autonomous vehicles
uh health diagnosis suggestions
prescriptions and autonomous
weapons systems they didn't mention this
in their content and i was just like
doing some additional research and
research i'm like
yeah you really don't want mistakes when
you have automated weapons or ethically
you shouldn't have them at all but
hey that's uh that's just how the world
works but yeah this is this category
here
we're on to our third microsoft ai
principle ai system should be secure and
respect privacy so ai can require vast
amounts of data to train deep machine ml
models the nature of an ml model may
require
personally identifiable information so
piis
it is important that we ensure
protection of user data that it does not
leak or disclose in some cases ml models
can be run locally on a user's device so
their
piis remain on their device of avoiding
the the vulnerability
this is called this is like edge
computing so that's the concept there
ai security principles such as malicious
actors so data origin and lineage
data use internal versus external data
corruption considerations
anomaly detection so there you go
[Music]
we're on to the fourth microsoft ai
principle so ai systems should empower
everyone and engage people
if we can design ai solutions for the
minority of users they can design ai
solutions for the majority of users so
we're talking about minority groups
we're talking about
physical ability gender sexual
orientation ethnicity other factors
this one's really simple uh in terms of
practicality it doesn't
100 make sense because if you've worked
with
groups that are deaf and blind
developing technology for them a lot of
times they need specialized solutions
uh but the approach here is that you
know if we can design for the minority
we can design for all that is
uh the principle there so that's what we
need to know okay
let's take a look here at transparency
so ai systems should be understandable
so
interpretability and intelligibility is
when the end user can understand the
behavior of ui so
transparency of ai systems can result in
mitigating unfairness
help developers debug their ai systems
getting more trust from our users
those builds those who build ai systems
should be
open about why they're using ai open
about the limitations of the i systems
adopting an open source ai framework can
provide transparency
at least from a technical perspective on
the internal workings
of an ai system
[Music]
we are on to the last microsoft ai
principle here people
should be accountable for ai systems so
the structure put in place to
consistently enacting ai principles and
taking them into account ai systems
should work within frameworks of
governments
organizational principles ethical and
legal standards that are clearly defined
principles guide microsoft on how they
develop sell and advocate when working
with third parties and this push
towards regulation towards a principle
so this is microsoft saying hey
everybody adopt
our model um there are many other models
so i guess it's great that microsoft is
taking the charge there i just feel that
it needs to be
a bit more well developed but what we'll
do is look at some more practical
examples so we can better understand
how to apply their principles okay
so if we really want to understand how
to apply the microsoft ai principles
they've
created this nice little tool via a free
web app for practical scenarios so they
have these cards you can read through
these cards
they're color coded for different
scenarios and there's a website so let's
go take a look at that and see what we
can learn okay
[Music]
all right so we're here on the
guidelines for human ai interaction so
we can better
understand the uh how to put into
practice the microsoft ai principles
they have 18 cards and let's work our
way through here and see the examples
the first one our list
make clear what the system can do help
the users understand what the ai system
is capable of doing
so here powerpoint quick start builders
and online builds an online outline to
help you get started researching a
subject
it displays suggested topics that help
you understand the features capability
then we have the bing app shows examples
of types of things you can search for
apple watch displays all metrics it
tracks and explains how going on the
second card we have make clear how
well the system can do what it can do so
here we have office new
companion experience ideas dock
alongside your work
and offers one-click assistance with
grammar design data insights richer
images and more
the unassuming term ideas coupled with
label previews help set expectations and
presented suggestions
the recommender in apple music uses
language such as
we will think you'll like to communicate
uncertainty
the help page for outlook webmail
explains the filtering into focused and
other
and will start working right away but
will get better with use making clear
the mistakes
will happen and you teach the product
and set overrides onto our red cards
here
we have time services based on context
time when to act
or interrupt based on the user's current
task and environment
when it's time to leave for appointments
outlook sends a time to leave
notification
with directions for both driving and
public transit taking into account
current location event location
real-time traffic information
and then we have after using apple maps
routing it remembers when you're parked
your car
when you open the app after a little
while it suggests routing to the
location of the parked car
all these apple examples make me think
that microsoft has some kind of
partnership with apple
i guess i guess microsoft or or bill
gates did own
apple shares so maybe they're closer
than we think show contextually relevant
information time when to act or
interrupt based on user's current task
and environment
powered by machine learning acronyms in
word helps you understand
shorthand employed in your own work
environment relative to
current open document uh on walmart.com
when the user is looking at a product
such as gaming console it recommends
accessories and games that it would go
with it when a user searches for movies
google
shows results including show times near
the user's location for the current data
onto our fifth card here match based uh
we didn't we didn't miss this one right
yeah we did okay so we're on the fifth
one here match relevant social norms
ensure experience is delivered in a way
the users would expect
given the social cultural context when
editor identifies ways to improve
writing style
prints optionals politely consider using
that's the canadian way being polite
google photos is able to recognize pets
and use the wording
important cats and dogs recognizing that
for many pets are
an important part of one's family and
you know what uh when i
started renting my new house uh i said
you know these are probably dogs and my
landlord said
well of course pets are part of the
family and that was something i like to
hear
cortana uses semi formal tone
apologizing when
unable to find a contact which is polite
and socially appropriate i like that
okay mitigate social biases ensure ai
system
languages and behaviors do not reinforce
undesirable unfair stereotypes and
biases
my analytics summarizes how you spend
your time at work
then suggest ways to work smarter one
ways to mitigate bias is by using gender
neutral icons to represent
important people sounds good to me a
bing search for ceo
or doctor shows images of diverse people
in terms
of gender and necessity sounds good to
me the predictive
uh keyboard for android suggests both
genders when typing a pronoun
starting with the letter h we're on to
our
yellow cards uh to support efficient
invocations so make it easy to invoke or
request a system services when needed so
flash fill is a helpful time saver in
excel that can be easily invoked
with on-canvas interactions and that
keep you in flow
on amazon.com oh hey there got amazon in
addition to the system giving
recommendations
as you browse you can manually invoke
additional recommendations from the
recommender
for your menu design ideas in microsoft
powerpoint can
be invoked uh with the with the press of
a button
if needed i cannot stand it when that
pops up i always have to
tell it to leave me alone okay support
efficient dismal uh
efficient dismissal
dismissal oh support efficient dismissal
okay make it easy to dismiss or ignore
under undesired ai system services
okay this sounds good to me microsoft
forms allows you to create custom
surveys quizzes polls questionnaires and
forums
some choices questions trigger suggested
options position beneath
the relevant question the suggestion can
be easily ignored and dismissed
instagram allows the user to easily hide
or report ads that have been
suggested by ai by tapping the ellipses
at the top of the right of the ad
siri can be easily dismissed by saying
never mind i'm always telling my alexa
never mind support efficient uh
correction make it easy to edit refine
or recover the ai system
uh when the when the ai system is wrong
so alt auto alt text
automatically generates alt text for
photographs by using intelligent
services in the cloud descriptions can
be easily modified by clicking the alt
text
button in the ribbon once you set a
reminder with siri the ui displays a tap
to edit link
when bing automatically corrects
spelling errors in search queries it
provides the option to revert
to the query as originally typed with
one click onto
card number 10 scope services when in
doubt so engage
in dis ambiguous and
dis and biguation or gracefully degrade
the ai system service
when uncertain about a user's goal so an
auto replacement word is uncertain of a
correction it engages in
disambiguation by displaying multiple
options you can select from
siri will let you know it has trouble
hearing if you don't respond or talk or
or speak too softly bing maps will
provide multiple routing options when
uh when unable to recommend best one
we're on to card number 11.
make clear why the system did what it
did enable users to access
an explanation of why the ai system
behaved as it did
office online recommends document
documents based on
history and activity descriptive text
above each document makes it clear why
the recommendation is shown
product recommendations on amazon.com
include why recommend recommended link
that shows that what products in the
user's shopping history informs
the recommendations facebook enables you
to access an explanation about
why you are seeing each ad in the news
feed
onto our green cards so remember recent
interactions so
maintain short-term memory and allow the
user to make efficient references to
that memory
when attaching a file outlook offers a
list of recent files including recently
copied file links
outlook also remembers people you have
interacted with recently and displays
them when addressing a new email
bing search remembers some recent
queries and search can be continued
uh conversationally how old is he after
a search for huanu reeves
siri carries over the context from one
interaction to the next a text message
is created from the person you told siri
to message two
on to card number thirteen lucky number
thirteen
learn from user behavior personalize the
user experience by learning
from their actions over time tap on a
search bar in office applications and
search
lists the top three commands on your
screen
that you're most likely to need to
personalize the technology called
xero query doesn't even need to type in
the search bar to provide a personalized
predictive answer
amazon.com gives personalized product
recommendation recommendations based on
previous purchases onto card 14.
update and adapt cautiously
limit disruptive changes when updating
adaptive adapting the ai systems
behaviors so
powerpoint designer improves slides for
office 65 subscribers by automatically
generating design ideas from
to choose from designer has integrated
new capabilities such as smart graphics
icon suggestions and existing user
experience ensuring
the updates are not disruptive office
tell
office tell me feature shows dynamically
recommended items
and a designated try area to minimize
disruptive
changes onto card number 15. encourage
granular feedback
enable the users to provide feedback
indicating their preferences during
regular interactions with the ai system
so ideas in excel empowers you to
understand your data through high
level visual summaries trends and
patterns encourages feedback on each
suggestion by asking is this helpful not
only does instagram provide the option
to hide specific ads but it also
solicits feedback to understand why the
ad is not relevant
and apple's music app love dislike
buttons are prominent
easily accessible number 16 convey the
consequences of user actions immediately
update or convey how user actions will
impact future behaviors of the ai system
you can get stock and geographic data
types in excel
it is easy as typing text into a cell
and converting it to stock data
type or geography data type when you
perform the conversion action an icon
immediately appears in the converted
cells
upon tapping the like dislike button for
each recommendation
in apple music a pop-up informs the user
that they'll receive
more or fewer similar recommendations
onto card number 17
or almost near the end provide global
controls allow the user to globally
customize the i system
system monitors and how it behaves so
editor expands on spelling
and grammar checking capabilities of
word to include more advanced proofing
and editing designed to ensure
document is readable editor can flag a
range of critique types and allow to
customize
the thing is is that in word it's so
awful spell checking i don't understand
like
it's been years and the spell checking
never gets better so they're going to
employ a better
spell checking ai i think bank search
provides settings that impact
the types of results the engine will
return for example
safe search uh then we have
google photos allows users to turn
location history on and off for future
photos
it's kind of funny seeing like bing in
there about like using ai because at one
point it's
almost pretty certain that bing was
copying just google search indexes to
learn how to index
i don't know that's microsoft for you uh
we're on to cart 18 notify users about
changes
inform the user when ai system adds or
updates its capabilities
uh the what's new dialog in office
informs you about changes by giving an
overview of the latest features and
updates including
updates to ai features in outlook web
the help
tab includes a what's new section that
covers
updates so there we go we made it to the
end of the list
i hope that was a fun listen for you and
and
there i hope that we could kind of match
up the uh
the responsible ai i kind of wish what
they would have done is actually mapped
it out here and
say word match but i guess it's kind of
an isolated service that kind of ties in
so i guess there we go okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure cognitive
services and this is a comprehensive
family of ai services
and cognitive apis to help you build
intelligent apps so create customizable
pre-trained models built with
breakthrough ai researches i put that in
quotations i'm kind of throwing some
shade
at microsoft azure just because it's
their marketing material right
deploy cognitive services anywhere from
cloud to the edge
with containers get started quickly no
machine learning expertise required
but i think it helps to have a bit of
background knowledge
developed with strict ethical standards
uh microsoft
loves talking about the responsible um
there's responsible ai stuff
empowering responsible use with industry
leading tools and guidelines so
let's do a quick breakdown of the types
of services in this family so for
decision we have anomaly detector
identify potential problems early on
content moderator detect potentially
offensive or unwanted content
personalize or create rich personalized
experiences for every user
for languages we have language
understanding also known as
l-u-i-s lewis i don't know i didn't put
the initialism there but don't worry
we'll see it again
build natural language understanding
into app spots and iot devices
q a maker create a conversational
question and answer layer
over your data text analytics detect
sentiment so sentiment is like whether
customers are happy sad
glad uh keep phrases and named entities
translator detect and translate more
than 90 supported languages
for speech we have speech to text so
transcribe audible
speech into readable search text text to
speech convert text to life like speech
for natural
interfaces speech translation so
integrate
real time speech translation into your
apps speaker recognition
identify and verify the people speaking
based on
audio for vision uh we have computer
vision so analyze content
in images and videos custom vision so
analyze or sorry
customize image record or image
recognition to fit your business needs
face detect and identify people and
emotions
in images so there you go
[Music]
so azure cognitive services is an
umbrella ai
service that enables customers to access
multiple ai services with an ai key and
api endpoint so what you do is you go
create a new cognitive service
and once you're there it's going to
generate two keys and an endpoint and
that is what you're using generally for
authentication
with the various ai services
pragmatically and that is something that
is key to the service that you need to
know
[Music]
so knowledge mining is a discipline in
ai that uses a combination of
intelligent services to quickly learn
from vast amounts of information so it
allows organizations to deeply
understand and easily explore
information
uncover hidden insights and find
relationships and patterns at scale so
we have ingest
enrich and explore those are three steps
so for ingest content from a range of
sources using connectors to first
and third-party data stores so we might
have structured data such as databases
csvs
uh the csvs would more be
semi-structured but we're not going to
get into that level of detail
unstructured data so pdfs videos images
and audio
for enrich the content with ai
capabilities that let you extract
information find patterns and deepen
understanding
so cognitive services like vision
language speech decision
and search and explore the newly indexed
data via search bots existing
businesses applications and data
visualizations enriched
structured data customer relationship
management
rap systems power bi this whole
knowledge mining thing is a thing but
like
i believe that the whole model around
this is so that azure
uh shows you how you can use the
cognitive services to solve
uh things without having to invent new
solutions so let's look at a bunch of
use cases that azure has and see where
we can find some
useful use so the first one here is for
content research so
when organizations task employees review
and research
of technical data it can be tedious to
read page after page of dense text
knowledge mining helps employees quickly
review these dense materials so you have
a document
and in the enrichment step you could be
doing printed text recognition
key phrase extraction sharpener sharpen
skills technical keyword sanitation
format definition minor large scale
vocabulary matcher
you put it through a search service and
now you have search reference library so
it makes things a lot easier to work
with
now we have audit risk compliance
management so developers could use
knowledge mining to help
attorneys quickly identify entities of
importance from discovery documents and
flag important ideas across
documents so we have documents so clause
extraction clause
classification gdpr risk named
identity extraction key phrase
extraction language detection automate
translation
uh then you put it back into a search
index and now you can use a management
platform or
a word plugin and so we have business
process management in industries where
bidding competition is fierce or when
the diagnosis of a problem must be quick
or in me or
real time companies use knowledge mining
to avoid costly
mistakes so the client drilling and
completion reports
document processor ai services and
custom models queue for
human validation intelligent automation
you send it to a back-end system or a
data lake
and or a data lake and then you do your
analytics dashboard
then we have customer support and
feedback analysis
so for many companies customer support
is costly and
efficient knowledge mining can help
customers support teams quickly find the
right
answers for a customer inquiry or assess
customer sentiment at scale so you have
your source data
you do your document cracking use
cognitive skills so pre-trained services
are custom
you have enriched documents from here
you're going to do your projections
and have a knowledge store you're going
to have a search index and then do your
analytics something like power bi
we have digital assessment management i
know there's a lot of these but it
really helps you understand how
cognitive services are going to be
useful
given the amount of unstructured data
created daily many companies are
struggling to make use of or find
information within their files
knowledge mining through a search index
makes it easy for end customers and
employees to locate what they're looking
for faster
so you can just like art metadata and
the actual images themselves
for the top layer we're doing geopoint
extractor biographical enricher then
down below we're tagging we're custom
object detector similar image tagger we
put it in a search index they love those
search indexes
and now you have an art explorer
we have contract management this is the
last one here many companies create
products
for multiple sectors hence the business
opportunities with different vendors
and buyers increase exponentially
knowledge mining can help organizations
to scour thousands of pages of sources
to create
accurate bids so here we have rfp
documents
um this will actually probably come back
later in the original set but we will
will do risk extraction print text
recognition
key phrase extraction organizational
extraction engineering standards we'll
create a search index and put it here
this will bring back data also metadata
extraction will come back here and then
this is just like a continuous pipeline
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at
face service and azure face service
provides an ai algorithm that can detect
recognize and analyze human faces and
images
such as a face and an image faced with
specific attributes
face landmarks similar faces and the
same face as a specific identity
across a gallery of images so here's an
example of an image
that i ran that we'll do in the follow
along and
what it's done is it's drawn a bounding
box around the image and there's this id
and this is a unique identifier string
for each detected face and an image and
these can be unique across the gallery
which is really useful as well
another cool thing you can do is face
landmarks
so the idea is that you have a face and
it can identify very particular
components of it
and up to 27 predefined landmarks is
what is provided with this face service
another interesting thing is face
attributes so you can uh
check whether they're wearing
accessories so think like earrings or
lip rings uh determine its age uh the
blurriness of the image
what kind of emotion is being experience
the exposure of the image
you know the contrast facial hair gender
glasses uh your hair in general
the head pose there's a lot of
information around that makeup which
seems to be limited like when we ran it
here
in the lab all we got back was eye
makeup and lip makeup but hey
we get some information whether they're
wearing a mask
uh noise so whether there's artifacts
like visual artifacts
or occlusion so whether an object is
blocking
the parts of the face and then they
simply have a boolean value for whether
the person's smiling or not which i
assume is a very common component so
that's pretty much all we really need to
know about the face service and there
you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the speech and
translate service so azure's translate
service is a
translation service as the name implies
and it can translate 90 languages and
dialects and i was even surprised to
find out that it can translate
into klingon and it uses a neural
machine translation
nmt replacing its legacy statistical
machine
translation smt so what my guess here is
that statistical meaning that it used
classical machine learning back
in 2010 and and then they decided to
switch it over to
neural networks um which of course would
be a lot more accurate
azure translate service can support a
custom translator so it allows you to
extend the service
for translation based on your business
domain use cases so if you use a lot of
technical words and things like that
then you can fine-tune that or
particular phrases then there's the
other service azure speech service
and this is a a speech uh synthesis
service so what can do speech to text
text to speech
and speech translation so it's
synthesizing creating new voices
okay so we have speech to text so real
time speech to text batch
uh batching multi-device conversation
conversation transcription and you can
create custom speech models then you
have
text to speech so this utilizes a speech
synthesis markup language such as a way
of formatting it
and it can create custom voices uh then
you have the voice assistant so
integrates with the bot framework sdk
and speech recognition so speaker
verification and
identification so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at text analytics and
this is a service for nlp so natural
language processing
for text mining and text analysis so
text analytics can perform sentiment
analysis so find out what people think
about your brand or topic so features
provide
sentiment labels such as negative
neutral positive then you have opinion
mining which is
an aspect-based sentiment analysis it's
for granular information about the
opinions related to aspects
then you have key phrase extraction so
quickly identify the main concepts in
text
you have language detections to detect
the language of an inputted text that
it's written in
and you have name entity recognition so
ner so identify and categorize entities
in your text as people places objects
and quantities
and subset of ner is personally
identifiable
information so piis let's just look at a
few of these more in detail
some of them are very obvious but some
of these would help to have an example
so the first we're looking at is key
phrase extraction so
quickly identify the main concepts and
text so key phrase extraction works best
when you have
when you give it bigger amounts of text
to work on this is the opposite of
sentiment analysis which performs better
on smaller amounts of
text so document sizes can be 5 000 or
fewer characters per document
and you can have up to a thousand items
per collection so
imagine you have a movie review with a
lot of text in here and you want to
uh extract the key phrases so here
identified borg ship
enterprise um surface travels things
like that
uh then you have named entity
recognition so
this detects words and phrases mentioned
in unstructured data that can be
associated with one or more
semantic types and so here's an example
i think this is medicine based and so
the idea is that it's identifying
it's identifying um these words or
phrases
and then it's applying a semantic type
so it's saying like this is a diagnosis
this is a medication class and stuff
like that
semantic type could be more broad so
there's location event
a hybrid location twice here person
diagnosis age and there is a predefined
set i believe that is in
azure that you should expect but they
have a generic one and then there's one
that's for
health we're looking at sentiment
analysis this graphic makes it uh
make a lot more sense when we're
splitting between sentiment and opinion
mining
but the idea here is that sentiments
analysis will apply labels and
confidence scores
to text at the sentence and document
level
and so labels can include negative
positive mixed or neutral
and we'll have a confidence score
ranging from zero to one
and so over here we have a sentiment
analysis of this
line here and saying that this was a
negative sentiment but look there's
something that's positive and there's
something that's negative so was it
really negative and that's where opinion
mining gets
really useful because it has more
granular data where we have a subject
and we have an opinion
right and so here we can see the room
was great but the staff was unfriendly
and negative so we have a bit of a split
there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at optical character
recognition also known as
ocr and this is the process of
extracting printed or handwritten text
into a digital and editable format so
ocr can be applied to
photos of street signs products
documents invoices bills
financial reports articles and more and
so here's an example
of us extracting out nutritional data or
nutritional facts
off the back of a food product so
azure has two different kinds of apis
that can perform ocr
they have the ocr api and the read api
so the ocr api uses an older recognition
model
it supports only images it executes
synchronous synchronously
returning immediately when uh it detects
text
it's suited for less text it supports
more languages
it's easier to implement and on the
other side we have the read api
so this is an updated recognition model
supports images and pdfs
executes asynchronously paralyzes
tasks per line for faster results suited
for
lots of text supports fewer languages
and it's a bit more difficult to
implement and so when we want to use
this service
we're going to be using computer vision
sdk okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at form
recognizer service this is a specialized
ocr service that translates printed text
into digital and editable content
it preserves the structure and
relationships of the form like data
that's what makes it so special
so form recognizer is used to automate
data entry in your applications and
enrich your document search capabilities
it can identify key value pairs
selection marks table structures
it can produce output structures such as
original file relationships
bounding boxes confidence score and form
recognizer is composed of a custom
document processing models pre-built
models for invoices receipts ids
business cards
the model layouts let's talk about the
layout here so extract text
selection marks table structures along
with bounding box coordinates from
documents
format recognizer can extract text
selection marks and table structures the
row and column numbers associated with
the text
using high definition optical character
enhancement models
that is totally useless that text
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at form recognizer
service and this is a specialized
service
uh for ocr that translates printed text
into digital editable content but the
magic here is that it preserves the
structure and relationship of form like
data so
there's an invoice you see those magenta
lines it's saying identify
that form like data so form recognizer
is used to automate data entry in your
applications and enrich your document
search capabilities
and it can identify key value pairs
selection marks table structures
and it can output structures such as
original file relationships bounding box
boxes confidence scores it's composed of
a customer
custom document processing model
pre-built models for invoices receipts
ids and business
cards it's based on this layout model
and there you go
[Music]
so let's touch upon custom models so
custom models allow you to extract text
key value pairs selection marks
and tabular data from your forms these
models are trained with your data
so they're tailored to your forums you
only need five samples
sample input forms to start a training
document processing model can output
structured data that includes the
relationship in the original form
document
after you train them all you can test
and retrain it and eventually use it
reliably extract data from
more forms according to your needs you
have two learning options you have
unsupervised learnings to understand the
layout the relationships between
fields entries and your forms and you
have supervised learning to extract
values of interest
using the labeled form so we've covered
unsupervised and supervised learning so
you're going to be very familiar with
these two
okay
[Music]
so form recognizer service has many
pre-built models
that are easy to get started with and so
let's go
look at them and see what kind of fields
it extracts out by default
so the first is receipts so sales
receipts from australia canada great
britain india and united states will
work great
here and the fields it will correct out
is receipt type merchant name merchant
phone number
merchant address transaction date
transaction time total subtotal tax tip
items name quantity price total price if
there's information that is on
a receipt that you're not getting out of
these fields and that's where you make
your own custom model right
for business cards it's only available
for english business cards but
we can extract out contact names first
name last name company names departments
job titles emails websites addresses
mobile phones faxes work phones and
other phone numbers not sure how many
people are using
business cards these days but hey they
have it as an option
for invoices extract data from invoices
in various formats and return structured
data
so we have customer name customer id
purchase order invoice id invoice date
due date vendor name vendor address
vendor address receipt customer address
customer address receipt billing address
billing address receipt shipping address
subtotal total tax invoice total amount
due service address
remittance address start service start
date and end date
previous unpaid balance and then they
even have one for line items so items
amount description quantity unit price
product code unit date
tax and then for ids which could be
worldwide passports us driver license
things like that
um you would have fields such as country
region date of birth date of expire
expiration document name first name last
name nationality sex
machine readable zone i'm not sure what
that is
document type and address and region
and there are some additional features
with some of these models we didn't
really cover them it's not that
important but um yeah there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at natural
uh understanding or lewis or luis
it depends on how you like to say it and
this is a no code ml service to build
language
uh natural language into apps bots and
iot devices so quickly create enterprise
ready
custom models that continuously improve
so louis i'm going to just call
this because that's what i prefer is
access via its own isolate domain
at lewis dot ai and it utilizes
nlp and nlu so n i'll use the ability to
perform
or ability to transform a linguistic
statement to a representation
that enables you to understand your
users naturally and it is intended to
focus on intention
and extraction okay so where the users
want or
sorry what the users want and what the
users are talking about
so the lewis application is composed of
a schema
and the schema is auto-generated for you
when you use the lewis ai web interface
so
you definitely are going to be writing
this by hand but it just helps to see
what's kind of in there
if you do have some programmatic skills
you obviously you can make better use of
the service than just the web interface
but the schema defines intentions so
what the users are asking for
a loose app always contains a none
intent we'll talk about why that is in a
moment
and entities what parts of the intent is
used to determine the answer
then you also have utterances so
examples of the user input that includes
intent and entities to train the ml
model
to match predictions against the real
user input
so an intent requires one or more
example utterance for training
and it is recommended to have 15 to 30
example utterances
to explicitly train uh to ignore an
utterance you use the none
intent so intent
classifies user utterances and entities
extract data from utterances so
hopefully that understands i always get
the stuff mixed up it always takes me a
bit of time to understand
there is more than just these things
there's like features and other things
but you know for
the ai 900 we don't need to go that deep
okay
just get to visualizing this to make a
bit easier so imagine we have this
uh this utterance here these would be
the identity so we have two
in toronto this is the example utterance
and then the idea is that you'd have the
intent
the intent and if you look at this
keyword here this really helps where it
says classify it's that's what it is
it's a classification
of this example utterance and that's how
the ml model is going to learn okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at q a maker
service and this is a cloud-based nlp
service that allows you to create a
natural conversational layer over your
data
so q a maker is hosted on its own
isolate domain at q a maker dot ai
it will help the most it will help you
find the most appropriate answer from
any
input from your custom knowledge base of
information so
you can commonly it's commonly used to
build conversation clients which include
social apps chat bots
speech enabled desktop applications
q a maker doesn't store customer data
all the customer data is stored in the
region the customer deploys the
the dependent services instances within
okay so
let's look at some of the use cases for
this so when you have static information
you can use
q a maker in your knowledge base of
answers this knowledge base is custom to
your needs which you've built with
documents such as pdf and urls
when you want to provide the same answer
to a repeat question command when
different users submit the same question
the answers
is returned when you want to filter
stack information based on meta
information
so meta tag data is provide uh provides
additional filtering options relevant to
your client application users and
information common metadata information
includes chit chat
content type format content purpose
content freshness
and there's a use case when you want to
manage a bot conversation that includes
static information so your knowledge
base takes
uh takes a user conversational text or
command
and answers it if the answer is part of
a predetermined conversation flow
represented in the knowledge base with
multiple turnkey contexts the bot can
easily provide this
flow so q a maker imports your content
into a knowledge base of questions
and answer pairs and qma maker can build
your knowledge base from an existing
document manual
or website you're all docx pdf i thought
this was the coolest thing so you can
just basically have anyone write a docx
as long as it has a heading and a
and text and i think you can even
extract that images and it'll just
turn it into the bot it just saves you
so much time it's crazy
it will use ml to extract the question
and answer pairs the content of the
question of answer pairs include
all the alternate forms of the question
meta dag tags used to filter
choices during the search follow-up
prompts to continue the search
refinement uh refinement
q a maker stores answers text in
markdown
once your knowledge base is imported you
can fine tune the imported results by
editing the
question and answer pairs as seen here
uh there is the chat box so you can
converse with your bot through a chat
box i wouldn't say this particularly a
feature of
q a maker but i just want you to know
that's how you'd interact with it so
when you're using the q a maker ai the
azure bot service the block composer
or via channels you'll get an embeddable
one you'll see this box where you can
start typing in your questions
and and get back the answers to test it
here an example is a multi-turn
conversation so somebody asked a
question a generic question
and then said hey are you talking about
aws or azure which is kind of like a
follow-up prompt
and we'll talk about multi-turning here
in a second but uh that's something i
want you to know about okay
so chit chat is a feature in q a maker
that allows you to easily add
pre-populated sets of
top chit chats into your knowledge base
the data set has about 100 scenarios of
chit chat in
voices of multiple personas so the idea
is like if someone says something random
like
how are you doing what's the weather
today things that your bot wouldn't
necessarily know
it has like canned answers and it's
going to be different based on how you
want
the response to be okay there's a
concept of layered rankings so
q a maker system is a layered ranking
approach the data is stored in azure
search which also serves as the first
ranking layer
the top result for uh from azure search
are then passed through q a makers
nlp re-ranking model to produce the
final results and confidence score
touching on multi-turn conversation is a
follow-up prompt
and context to manage the multiple turns
known as multi-turn for your bot
from one question to another when a
question can't be answered in a single
turn that is when you're using
multi-turn conversation so q a maker
provides multi-term prompts and active
learning to help you improve your
questions based on key and answer pairs
and gives you the opportunity to connect
questions and answer pairs the
connection allows the client application
to provide a top answer
and provide more questions to refine the
search for a final answer
after the knowledge base receives
questions from users at the publish
endpoint
committeemaker applies active learning
to these ruler questions to suggest
changes to your knowledge base
to improve the quality all right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure bot service
so the azure bot service is
an intelligent serverless bot service
that scales on demand used for creating
publishing and managing bots so you can
register and publish a variety of bots
from the azure portal
so here there's a bunch of ones i've
never heard of probably with third-party
providers partnered with
azure and then there's ones that we
would know like the azure health bot the
azure bot
or the uh web app bot which is more of a
generic one
so azure bop service bop bot service can
integrate your bot with
other azure microsoft or third-party
service uh
services via channels so you can have a
direct line alexa
office 365 facebook geek
line microsoft teams skype uh
twilio and more all right and two things
that are commonly associated with the
azure bot service
is the bot framework and bot composer in
fact it was really hard just to make
make this slide here because they just
weren't very descriptive on it because
they wanted to push these other two
things here
but let's talk about the bot framework
sdk so the bot framework sdk
which is now version 4 is an open source
sdk that enables developers to model and
build sophisticated conversations
the bot framework along with the azure
bot service provides an
end-to-end workflow so we can design
build test
publish connect and evaluate our
bots okay with this with this framework
developers can create bots
they use speech understand uh natural
language handle questions answers and
more
the bot framework includes a module
extensible sdk for building bots as well
as tools templates and related ai
services
then you have bot framework composer and
this is built on top of the bot
framework sdk it's an open source
ide for developers to author test
provision and manage conversational
experiences
you can download it it's an app on
windows os x and linux is probably built
uh using like uh web technology and so
here is the actual uh app there and so
you can see there's kind of a bit of a
flow and things you can do in there
so you can either use c or node to build
your bot you can deploy
the bot to the azure web apps or azure
functions
you have templates to build q a makerbot
enterprise or personal assistant bot
language bot
calendar or peoplebot uh you can test
and debug via the bot framework emulator
and it has a built-in package manager
there's a lot more to these things but
again at the ai 900 this is all we need
to know
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure
machine learning service i want you to
know there's a classic version of the
service it's still
accessible in the portal this is not an
exam we are going to 100 avoid it
it has severe limitations we cannot
transfer anything
over from the classic to the new one uh
so the one we're going to focus on is
the azure machine learning service
you do create studios within it so
you'll hear me say azure machine
learning studio and i'm referring to the
new one
a service that simplifies running ai ml
work related workloads allowing you to
build flexible automated ml pipelines
use python or r run deep learning
workloads such as tensorflow
we can make jupiter notebooks in here so
build and document your machine learning
models as you build them
share and collaborate azure machine
learning sdk for python so an sdk
designed specifically to interact with
the azure machine learning services
it does ml ops machine learning
operations so end-to-end automation of
ml model pipelines cicd training
inference
azure machine learning designer so this
is a drag and drop interface to visually
build test deploy machine learning
models uh
technically pipelines i guess as a data
labeling service so
assemble a team of humans to label your
training data responsible machine
learning so model fairness
through disparity metrics and mitigate
unfairness at the time of the server
this is not very good but it's supposed
to tie in with
the responsible ai that microsoft is
always promoting okay
[Music]
so once we launch our own studio with an
azure machine learning service you're
gonna get this nice big bar
uh or navigation left-hand side that
shows you there's a lot of stuff that's
in here so let's just break it down and
what all these things are
so for authoring we've got notebooks
these are jupyter notebooks and ide to
write python code to build ml models
they kind of have their own preview
which i don't really like
but there is a way to bridge it over to
jupiter notebooks or to visual studio
code
we have auto ml completely automated
process to build and train ml models
so we're limited to only three types of
models but still that's great
we have the designer so visual drag and
drop designer to construct end-to-end
ml pipelines for assets we have data
sets so data that you can upload which
will be used
which will be used for training
experiments when you run a training job
they are detailed here pipelines ml
workflows
you have built or have used in the
designer model so a model registry
containing trained models that can be
deployed
endpoints so when you deploy a model
it's hosted on accessible endpoint
so you're going to be able to access it
via a rest api or maybe the sdk
for manage we got compute the underlying
computing instances used
for notebooks training and inference
environments a reproducible
python environment for machine learning
experiments data stores
a data repository where your data
resides data labeling
so you have a human with ml assisted
labeling to label your data for
supervised learning
link services external service you can
connect to the workspace such as azure
synapse analytics
let's take a look at the types of
compute that is available
in our azure machine learning studio we
got four categories
we have compute instances development
workstations that
data scientists can use to work with
data and models compute clusters to
scalable clusters of
vms for on-demand processing
experimentation code
deployment targets for predictive
services that use your trained models
and attach compute links to existing
azure compute resources such as
azure vms uh and azure data brick
clusters now uh what's interesting here
is like with this compute you can see
that you can open it in jupyter labs
jupyter vs code r
studio and terminal but you can you can
work with
your computer instances your development
workstations uh directly in the studio
which that's the way i do it
um what's interesting is for inference
that's when you want to make a
prediction
you use azure kubernetes service or
azure container instance and i didn't
see it show up under here so i'm kind of
confused whether that's where it appears
uh maybe we'll discover as we do the
follow alongs that they do appear here
but uh
i'm not sure about that one but yeah
those are the four there okay
so within azure machine learning studio
we can do some data labeling so we
create data labeling jobs to prepare
your ground truth for supervised
learning
we have two options human in the loop
labeling you have a team of humans that
will apply labeling these are humans you
grant access to
labeling machine learning assisted daily
labeling you will use ml to perform
labeling so you can export the label
data from for machine learning
experimentation anytime your users often
export multiple times and train
different models rather than wait for
all the images to be labeled
images labels can be exported in cocoa
format that's why we talked about coco
a lot earlier in our data sets section
as your machine learning data set
and this is the data set format that
makes it easy to use for training and
azure machine learning so
generally you want to use that format
the idea is you would choose a labeling
task type
uh and that way you would have this ui
and then people would go in and
and just click buttons and do the
labeling okay
so azure ml data store securely connects
you to storage services on azure without
putting your
authentication credentials and the
integrity of your original data source
at risk so here
is the example of data stores that are
available to us in the studio
and let's just go quickly through them
so we have azure blob storage this is
data that is stored as objects
distributed across many machines
azure file share amountable file share
via smb and nfs protocols
as your data lake storage gen 2 this is
blob storage design for vast amounts of
big data analytics
azure sql this is a fully managed sql
relational database
azure postgres database this is an open
source relational database
often considered an object-related
database preferred by developers
azure mysql another open source solution
database the most popular one and
considered a pure relational database
okay
[Music]
so azure ml data sets makes it easy to
register your data sets for use with
your
ml workload so what you do is you add a
data set and you get a bunch of
metadata associated with it and you can
also upload
a dish like the data set again to have
multiple versions so you'll have a
current version and a latest
version it's very easy to get started
working with them because they'll have
some sample code
that's for the azure ml sdk to import
that into
uh into your jupyter notebooks for data
sets you can generate
profiles that will give you summary
statistics distribution of data and more
you will have to use a compute instance
to generate that data so you'd press the
generate profile and you'd have that
stored i think it's in blob storage
there are open data sets these are
publicly hosted data sets that are
commonly used for
learning how to build ml models so if
you go to open data sets you just choose
one and so
this is a curated list of open data sets
that you can quickly add to your data
store
great for learning how to use automl or
azure machine learning designer
or any kind of ml workload if you're new
to it that's why we covered
mnist and coco earlier just because
those are some common data sets there
but there you go
[Music]
taking a look here at azure ml
experiments this is a logical grouping
of azure runs and runs act
uh is the act of running an ml task on a
virtual machine or container
so here's a list of them and it can run
various
types of ml tasks so scripts could be
pre-processing automl
a training pipeline but what it's not
going to include is inference what i
mean is once you've deployed your model
or pipeline
and you uh make predictions via a
request it's just not going to show up
under here
okay
[Music]
okay so we have azure ml pipelines which
is an executable workflow of a complete
machine learning task not to be confused
with azure pipelines which is part of
azure devops or data factory which has
its own pipelines it's a total
totally separate thing here so subtasks
are encapsulated as a series of steps
within the pipeline independent steps
allow multiple data scientists
to work on the same pipeline at the same
time without over tax and compute
resources
separate steps also make it easy to use
different compute type sizes for each
step
when you rerun a pipeline the run jumps
to the steps
that need to be rerun such as the
updated training script steps do not
need to be rerun
and they will be skipped after a
pipeline has been published you can
configure a rest endpoint which allows
you to rerun the pipeline from any
platform or stack
there's two ways to build pipelines you
can use the azure
ml designer or pragmatically using azure
machine learning
python sdk so here is example of some
code
just make a note here i mean it's not
that important but notices you create
steps
okay and then you assemble all the steps
into a pipeline here
all right
[Music]
so azure machine learning designer lets
you quickly build azure ml pipelines
without having to write any code so here
is what it looks like
and over there you can see our pipeline
is quite visual
and on the left hand side you have a
bunch of assets you can drag out that
are
pre-built there so it's a really fast
way for building a pipeline so you do
have to have a good understanding of
ml pipeline's end-to-end to make good
use of it once you've
trained your pipeline you can create an
inference pipeline so you drop down
and you'd say whether you want it to be
real or batch and you can
toggle between them later so i mean
there's a lot to this service but
for the ai 900 we don't have to go
diving too deep okay
[Music]
so azure ml models or the model registry
allows you to create manage and track
your registered models as incremental
versions under the same name
so each time you register a model with
the same name as an existing one the
registry assures that it's a new version
additionally you can provide metadata
tags and use tags when you search for
models
so yeah it's just a really easy way to
share and deploy or download your models
okay
[Music]
azure mlm points allow you to deploy
machine learning models as a web service
so the workflow for deploying model is
registered the model prepare an entry
script repair and inference
configuration
deploy the model locally to ensure
everything works compute
choose a compute target redeploy the
model
to the cloud test the resulting web
service so we have uh
two options here real-time endpoints so
an endpoint that provides remote access
to invoke the ml model
uh service running on either azure
kubernetes service aks
or azure container instance aci then we
have pipeline endpoints so an endpoint
that provides remote access to invoke an
ml pipeline
you can parameterize the pipeline
endpoint for managed repeatability in
batch scoring and retraining scenarios
and so you can deploy a model to an
endpoint it will either be deployed to
aks or aci as we said earlier uh and the
thing is is that when you do do that
just understand that that's going to be
shown
under the aks or aci within the azure
portal
it's not consolidated under the azure
machine learning studio
when you've deployed a real-time
endpoint you can test the endpoint by
sending either a single request or batch
request so they have a nice form here
where it's single
or it's um like here it's a csv you can
send so there you go
so azure has a built-in jupyter-like
notebook editor so you can build and
train your ml models and so here is an
example
of it i personally don't like it too
much but that's okay because we have
some other options to make it easier
what you do is you choose your compute
instance to run the notebook you'll
choose your kernel uh which is
a pre-loaded programming language and
programming libraries for different use
cases
but that's a jupiter kernel concept
there
so you can open the notebook in a more
familiar id such as vs code
jupyter notebook classic or jupyter lab
so you go there
drop it down choose it and open it up
and now you're in a more familiar
territory
the vs code one is exactly the same
experience as the
the one in azure or azure ml studio
i personally don't like it i think most
people are going to be using the
notebooks but it's great that they have
all those options
[Music]
so azure automated machine learning also
known as auto ml automates the process
of creating an ml model so with azure
auto ml you supply a data set choose a
task type
uh and then automl will train and tune
your model so here are our task types
let's quickly go through them so we have
classification
when you need to make a prediction based
on several classes so binary
classification multi-class
classification
regression when you need to predict a
continuous number value and then
time series forecasting when you need to
predict the value based on time
so just look at them a little bit more
in detail so classification is the type
of supervised learning in which the
model learns using training data
and apply those learnings to new data so
here is an example
or this is just the option here and so
the goal of classification is to predict
which
categories new data will fall into based
on learning from its training data
so binary classification is a record uh
is labeled out of two possible labels so
maybe it's true or false
a zero or one it's just two values
multi-class classification is a record
is labeled out of range of out of a
range of labels
uh and so it could be like happy sad mad
or rad and just you know i can see
there's a smelly mistake there but
yeah there should be an f so let's just
correct that there we go
uh you can also apply a deep learning
and so if you turn deep learning on you
probably will want to
use a gpu compute instance just because
or
compute cluster because deep learning
really prefers
gpus okay looking at regression it's
also a type of supervised learning where
the model
learns uh using training data and
applies those learnings to new data
but it's a bit different where the goal
of regression is to predict a variable
in the future
then you have time series forecasting
and this sounds a lot like
regression because it is so forecast
revenue inventory sales or
customer demand an automated time series
experiment that is treated as a
multi-variant regression problem
past time series values are pivoted to
become additional dimensions for the
regressor together
with other predictors and unlike
classical
time series methods has an advantage of
naturally incorporating
multiple contextual variables and their
relationship to one another during
training
so use cases here or advanced
configurations i should say
holiday detection and futurization time
series uh
deep learning uh neural networks so you
got auto
a-r-i-m-a profit forecast tcn
many model supports through grouping
rolling origin cross validation
configurable labs
rolling window aggregate features so
there you go
[Music]
so within automl we have data guardrails
and
these are run by automl when automatic
featurization is enabled it's a sequence
of checks to ensure
high quality input data is being used to
train the models
just to show you some information here
so the idea is it could apply validation
split handling so the input data has
been split for
validation to improve the performance
then you have missing feature
value imputation so no features missing
values were detected in training data
high cardinality feature detection your
inputs were analyzed and no high
cardinality features were detected
by cardinality means like if you have
too many dimensions it becomes very
dense or hard to process the data
so that's something good to check
against
[Music]
let's talk about automl's automatic
featurization
so during model training with automl one
of the following scaling
or normalization techniques will be
applied to each model the first is
standard scale wrappers to standardize
features by removing the mean and
scaling to unit variants
min max scalar transform features by
scaling each feature by the column's
minimum maximum
max abs scaler scale each feature by its
maximum absolute value
robust scalar scales features by the
quantum quantile range
pca linear dimensionality reduction
using single
uh value decomposition of the data to
project it to
lower dimensional space uh dimension
reduction is very useful if your data is
too complex
let's say you have data and you have too
many labels
like 20 30 40 labels for per like for
categories to pick out of
you'll want to reduce the dimensions uh
so that your machine learning
model is not overwhelmed so then you
have truncated svd wrappers so the
transformer performs linear
dimensionality reduction by means of
truncated single
singular value decomposition contrary to
pca the estimator does not center the
data
before computing the singular value
decomposition which means it can work
with
spicy sparse matrices efficiently
sparse normalization each sample that is
each row of the data matrix which
uh with at least one zero component is
rescaled independently of other samples
so that is norm
so one l or two l two i can remember
it's i two or l
anyway uh i one and and i two
okay so the thing is is that on the exam
they're probably not going to be asking
these questions but i just like to get
you exposure but i just want to show you
that
automl is doing all this this is like
pre-processing stuff
you know like this is stuff that you'd
have to do and so it's just taking care
of the stuff for you okay
so within azure auto ml they have a
feature called
model selection and this is the task of
selecting a statistical model from a set
of candidate models
and azure auto ml will use different or
many different ml algorithms
that will recommend the best performing
candidates so here is a list and i want
to just point
out down below there's three pages
there's 53 models it's a lot of models
and so you can see that the one it chose
as its top candidate was called voting
ensemble that's an ensemble
algorithm that's where you take two weak
ml models combine them together to make
a more
uh stronger one and notice here it will
show us the results and this is what
we're looking for which is the primary
metric
the highest value should indicate that
that's the model we should want to use
you can get an explanation of the model
called uh that's
known as explainability and now if
you're a data scientist you might
be a bit smarter and say well i know
this one should be better so i'll use
this and tweak it
but you know if you don't know what
you're doing you just go with the top
one okay
[Music]
so we just saw that we had a top
candidate model
and there could be an explanation to
understand as to the effectiveness of
this
this is called mxl so machine learning
explainability this is the process of
explaining interpreting
ml or deep learning models mxmlx
can help machine learning developers to
better understand interpret model's
behavior so after your top candidate
model is selected by azure auto ml
you can get an explanation of internals
of various factors so model performance
data set explorer aggregate feature
importance individual future importance
so i mean yeah this is aggregate so what
it's looking at and it's actually cut
off here but it's saying that these are
the most important ones that affect how
the models outcome so i think this is
the diabetes
data set so bmi would be one that would
be a huge influencer there okay
[Music]
so the primary metric is a parameter
that determines the metric to be used
during the model training for
optimization so
for classification we have a few in
regression and time series we have a few
but you'll have these task types and
underneath you'll choose the additional
configuration
and that's where you can override the
primary metric uh it might just auto
detect it for you so you don't have to
because it might sample some of your
data set to just kind of guess
but you might have to overwrite it
yourself just going through some
scenarios
um and we'll break it down into two
categories so here we have suited for
larger data sets that are well balanced
well balanced means that your data set
like is evenly distributed so if you
have
uh uh cl classifications for a and b
let's say you have a hundred and a
hundred they're well balanced right
you don't have one data set much uh a
subset of your data much larger than the
other that's labeled
so for accuracy this is great for image
classification sentiment analysis turn
prediction
for average precision score weighted
it's for sentiment analysis
norm macro recalculation for precision
score weighted
uh uncertain as to what that would be
good for maybe sentiment analysis
suited for smaller data sets that are
inbound so that's where your data set
like you might have
like 10 records for one and 500 for the
other
on the label so you have auc weighted
fraud detection image classification
anomaly detection spam detection
onto regression scenarios uh we'll break
it down into
ranges so when you have a very wide
range spearmint correlation works really
well r2 score
this is great for airline delay salary
estimation bug resolution time
we're looking at smaller ranges we're
talking about normalized root square
mean to error so price predictions
um review tip score predictions for
normalized mean absolute error
it's going to be just another one here
they don't give a description for time
series it's the same thing it's just
in the context of time series so
forecasting all right
[Music]
another option we can change is the
validation type when we're setting up
our ml model so validation
model validation is when we compare the
results of our training data set to our
test data set model validation occurs
after we train the model and so you can
just drop it down there we have some
options so
auto k fold cross validation monte carlo
cross validation train validation
split i'm not going to really get into
the details of that i don't think it'll
show up on the ai 900 exam but
i just want you to be aware that you do
have those options okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at custom
vision and this is a fully managed no
code service to quickly build your own
classification
and object detection ml models the
service is hosted on its own isolate
domain
at www.customvision.ai so the first idea
is you upload your images so bring your
own labeled images or custom vision to
quickly add tags
to any unlabeled data images you use the
labeled images to teach custom vision
the concepts
you care about which is training and you
use a simple rest api that calls
uh to quickly tag images with your new
custom computer vision model so you can
evaluate okay
[Music]
so when we launch custom vision we have
to create a project and with that we
need to choose a project type and we
have classification
and object detection reviewing
classification here
you have the option between multi-labels
so when you want to apply many tags to
an image so think of an image that
contains both a cat
and a dog you have multi-class so when
you only have one possible tag to apply
to an image so
it's either an apple banana an orange
it's not
multiples of these things you have
object detection this is when we want to
detect various objects in an
image and you also need to choose a
domain a domain is a microsoft managed
data set that is used for training the
ml model
there are different domains that are
suited for different use cases so let's
go take a look first at image
classification domains
so here is the big list the domains
being over here
okay and we'll go through these here so
general is
optimized for a broad range of image
classification tasks if none of the
uh if none of the other specified
domains are appropriate or you're unsure
of which domain to choose select one of
the general domains so g
or a1 is optimized for better accuracy
with comparable inference time as
general domain recommended for larger
data sets or more difficult user
scenarios this domain requires more
training time
then you have a2 optimized for better
accuracy with faster adverts
times than a1 and general domains
recommended for more most data sets this
domain requires less training time
than general and a1 you have food
optimized for photographs or dishes of
as you would see them on a restaurant
menu if you want to classify photographs
of individual fruits or vegetables use
food domains
so then we have optimized for
recognizable landmarks both natural and
artificial
this domain works best when landmark is
clearly visible in the photograph this
domain works even if the land
mark is slightly obstructed by people in
front of it
then you have retail so optimized for
images that are found in a shopping cart
or shopping uh website if you want a
high precision classifying
classifying between dresses pants shirts
use this domain
compact domains optimized for the
constraints of real-time classification
on the edge okay
then we have object detection domain so
this one's a lot shorter so we'll get
through a lot quicker
so optimize for a broad range of object
detection tasks if none of the
other domains are appropriate or you're
unsure of which domain choose the
general one
a1 optimize for better accuracy and
comparable inference time than the
general domain recommended for most
accurate region locations larger data
sets or more difficult use case
scenarios the domain requires more
training results are not deterministic
expect uh plus
minus one percent mean average precision
difference uh with the same training
data provided you have
logo optimized for finding brands uh
logos and images
uh products on shelves so optimized for
detecting and classifying
products on the shelf so there you go
[Music]
okay so let's get some more practical
knowledge of the service so for image
classification you're going to upload
multiple images and apply a single or
multiple labels to the entire image
so here i have a bunch of images
uploaded and then i have my tags over
here
and they can either be multi or singular
for object detection you apply text to
objects in an image for data labeling
and you hover your cursor over the image
custom vision uses ml to show boundary
uh
bounding boxes of possible objects that
have not yet been labeled if it does not
detect it you can also just click and
drag to draw out
whatever square you want so here's one
where i tagged it up quite a bit
you have to have at least 50 images on
every tag to train
so just be aware of that when you are
tagging your images
when you're training your model is ready
when you and you have two options so you
have quick training this trains quickly
but
it will be less accurate you have
advanced training this increases compute
time to improve your results so for
advanced training basically you just
have this
thing that you move to the right with
each iteration of training
our ml model will improve the evaluation
metrics so precision recall
it's going to vary we're going to talk
about the metrics here in a moment but
the probability threshold value
determines when to stop training
when our evaluation metric meets our
desired threshold so these are just
additional options where when you're
training you can move this
left to right and these left to right
okay
and then when we get our results back
we're going to get some metrics here so
uh we have a valuation measure so we
have precision being exact and accurate
selects items that are relevant
recall such sensitivity or known as true
positive rate how many relevant items
returned
average precision it's important that
you remember these because they might
ask you that on the exam so for uh cut
when we're looking at object detection
and we're looking at the evaluation
metric outcomes for this one we have
precision
recall and mean average precision
once we've deployed our pipeline it
makes sense that we go ahead and give it
a quick test to make sure it's working
correctly
so you press the click quick test button
and you can upload your image and it
will tell you so this one says
it's worth when you're ready to publish
you just hit the publish button
and then you'll get uh some prediction
url and information so you can invoke it
one other feature that's kind of useful
is the smart labeler so once you've
loaded some training data within it can
now make suggestions right so you can't
do this
right away but once it has some data
it's like it's like kind of a prediction
that is not 100 guaranteed right and it
just helps you build up your training
data set a lot faster very useful if you
have a very large data set this is known
as
ml assisted labeling okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
set up a studio with an
azure machine learning service uh so
that
it will be the basis for all the follow
alongs here so what i want you to do is
go all the way the top here
and type in azure machine learning and
you're looking for this one that looks
like a
science uh bottle here and we'll go
ahead and create ourselves
our machine learning uh studio
and so i'll create a new one here and
i'll just say um
my studio
and we'll hit ok and we'll name the
workspace so we'll say
my work workplace
we'll maybe say ml workplace here
uh for containers there are none so it
will create all that stuff for us so
i'll hit create
and create
and so we're going to do here is just
wait for that creation okay
all right so after a short little wait
there it looks like our studio set up so
we'll go to that resource
launch the studio and we are now
in so there's a lot of stuff in here but
generally the first thing you'll ever
want to do is get yourself a notebook
going so in the top left corner i'm
going to go to notebooks
and what we'll need to do is load some
files in here now they do have some
sample files
like how to use azure ml so if we just
quickly go through here
you know maybe we'll want to look at
something like msnist here
and we'll go ahead and open this one
and we'll just go ahead and clone this
and we'll just clone it over here
okay and the idea is that we want to get
this notebook running and so notebooks
have to be backed by some kind of
compute
so up here it says no compute found and
etc so
what we can do here i'm just going to go
back to my files oh it went back there
for me
but what i'm going to do is go all the
way down actually i'll just expand this
up here makes it a bit easier
close this tab out but what we'll do is
go down to compute and here we have our
four
types of compute so compute instances is
when we're running notebooks
compute clusters is when we're doing
training inference clusters is when we
have
a inference pipeline and then attach
compute is bringing
things like hdinsights or data bricks
into here but for compute instances is
what we need
we'll get ahead and go new you'll notice
we have the option between cpu and gpu
gpu is much more expensive so it's like
90 cents per hour
for a notebook we do not need anything
uh super powerful notice it'll say here
development on notebooks
ids lightweight testing here it says
classical
ml model training automl pipelines etc
so i want to make this
a bit cheaper for us here because we're
going to be using
the notebook to run cognitive services
and those cost next to nothing like they
don't take much
compute power and for some other ones we
might do something a bit larger for this
this is good enough so i'll go ahead and
hit next
i'm just going to say my notebook
instance here we'll go ahead and hit
create and so we're just going to have
to wait for that to finish creating and
running and when it is i'll see you back
here in a moment
all right so after a short little wait
there looks like our server is running
and you can even see here it shows you
you can launch in jupiter labs jupiter
vs code rstudio or the terminal but
what i'm going to do is go back all the
way to our notebooks just so we have
some consistency here
i want you to notice that it's now
running on this compute if it's not you
can go ahead and select it
and it also loaded in python 3.6 there
is 3.8
right now it's not a big deal which one
you use um but that is the kernel like
how it will run the stuff
now this is all interesting but i don't
want to uh run this right now what i
want to do is get those
cognitive services into here so what we
can do
is just go up here and we'll choose
editors
and edit in jupyter lab and what that
should do is open up a new
tab here is it opening
if it's not opening what we can do is go
to compute sometimes it's a bit more
responsive if we just click there it's
the same way of getting to it
i don't know why but just sometimes that
link doesn't work when you're in the
notebook
and what we can do is while we're in
here now we can see that this is
where uh this example project is
okay but what we want to do is get those
cognitive services in here so
i don't know if i showed it to you yet
but i have a repository i just got to go
find it it's somewhere on my screen
um here it is okay so i have a repo
called the free a z
a z knight uh for freezing i it should
be ai 900
i think i'll go ahead and change that or
that is going to get
confusing okay so what i want you to do
here is
we'll get this loaded in so this is a
public directory i'm just thinking
there's a couple ways we can do it we
can go
and use the terminal to grab it what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to go
download the zip
and this is just one of the easiest ways
to install it and we need
um to place it somewhere so here are my
downloads
and i'm just going to drag it out here
okay and what we'll do is upload that
there so i can't remember if it lets you
upload entire folders we'll give it a go
see if it lets us
maybe rename this to the free az or ai
900 there
we'll say open uh yeah so it's
individual file so it's not that big of
a deal but we can go and head and select
it like that
and maybe i'll just make a new folder in
here we'll say this cognitive services
okay
and what we'll do here is keep on
uploading some stuff so
we have assets
so i have a couple loose files there
and i know we have crew
oops we'll have crew
oops sometimes it's not as responsive
we want ocr i believe we have one called
movie reviews
so we'll go into ocr here and upload the
files that we have
so we have a few files there
and we'll go back a directory here and i
know movie
reviews are just static files
and we have an objects folder
so we will go back here to objects
and then we'll go back and to crew and
we need a folder called
wharf a folder called crusher
a folder called data and so for each of
these we have some images
i think we're on wharf right yep we are
okay great
so we will quickly upload all these
oh well technically we don't really need
to upload any of these well uh these
images we don't but i'm going to put
them here anyway
i just remembered that these we just
upload directly to the service
but because i'm already doing anything
i'm just going to put them here even
though we're not going to do anything
with them
all right and so now we are all set up
to do some cognitive services so i'll
see the next video
all right so now that we have our work
environment set up what we can do
is go ahead and get cognitive services
hooked up because um
we need that service in order to
interact with it because if we open up
any of these you're going to notice we
have a cognitive key and endpoint that
we're going to need
so what i want you to do is go back to
your azure portal
and at the top here we'll type in
cognitive services
now the thing is is that all these
services are individualized but at some
point they did group them together and
you're able to use them through a
unified key and api endpoint that's what
this is and that's the way we're going
to do it
so we'll say add and
it brought us to the marketplace so i'm
just going to type in cognitive
services
and then just click this one here and
we'll hit create
and we'll make a new one here i'm going
to call my cog services
say okay um i prefer to be
in u.s east i believe in us west it's
fine and so in here we'll just say
my cog services
and if it doesn't like that i'll just
put some numbers in there we go
we'll do standard so we will be charged
something for that let's go take a look
at the pricing
so you can see that the pricing is quite
variable here but
it's like you'd have to do a thousand
transactions before you are billed
so i think we're going to be okay for
billing
we'll check boxes here we'll go down
below it's telling us about responsible
ai notice
sometimes services will actually have
you check box it but in this case it
just tells us there
and we'll go ahead and hit create
and i don't believe this took very long
so we'll give it a second here yep it's
all deployed so we'll go to this
resource here
and what we're looking for are our keys
and endpoints
and so we have two keys and two
endpoints we only need a single key so
i'm going to copy this endpoint over
we're going to go over to jupiter lab
and i'm just going to paste this in here
i'm just going to put it in all the ones
that need it so this one needs one
this one needs one this one needs one
and this one needs one and we will show
the key here
like it says in show but it copies of
course i will end up deleting my key
before you ever see it but this is
something you don't want to
share publicly and usually you don't
want to embed keys directly into
a notebook but this is the only way to
do it so this is how it is with azure
um so yeah all our keys are installed
uh going back to the cognitive services
uh nothing super exciting here but uh it
does tell us what services work with it
you'll see there's an asterisk beside
custom vision because we're gonna access
that through another app
but yeah cognitive services all set up
and so that means we are ready to
start doing some of these labs okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
computer vision first and computer
vision is actually used for a variety of
different services as you will see
it's kind of an umbrella for a lot of
different things but the one in
particular that we're looking at here
is the subscribe image in stream if we
go over here to the documentation
this operation generates description of
image in a human readable language
with complete sentences the description
is based on a collection of content tags
which also returned by the operation
okay so let's go see what that looks
like in action
so the first thing is is that we need to
install this azure cognitive services
vision computer vision
now we do have a kernel and these aren't
installed by default they're not part of
the
machine learning the azure machine
learning
sdk for python i believe that's
pre-installed but
these ai services are not so what we'll
do is go ahead and run it this way
and you'll notice where it says pip
install that's how it knows to install
and once that is done we'll go run our
requirements here so we have the os
which is for usually handling opt like
os
layer stuff we have matte matplotlib
which is to visually plot things and
we're going to use that to show images
and draw borders
we need to handle images i'm not sure if
we're using numpy here but i have numpy
loaded and then here we have the azure
cognitive services vision computer
vision
we're going to load the client and then
we have the credentials and these are
generic credentials for the cognitive
services credentials
it's commonly used for most of these
services and some exceptions
they the apis do not support them yet
but i imagine they will in the future
so just notice that when we run
something it will show a number if
there's an asterisk it means it hasn't
ran yet so i'll go ahead and hit play up
here
so it was an asterisk can we get a 2 and
we'll go ahead and hit
play again and now those are loaded in
and so we'll go ahead and hit play
okay so here we have just packaged our
credentials together so we passed our
key into here
and then we'll now load in the client
uh and so we'll pass our endpoint and
our key okay so hit play
and so now we just want to load our
image so here we're loading
assetsdata.jpg
let's just make sure that that is there
so we go assets and there it is
and we're going to load it as a stream
because you have to pass streams along
so hit play you'll see that it now ran
and so now we'll go ahead and make that
call
okay great so we're getting some data
back and notice we have some properties
person wall
indoor man pointing captions it's not
showing all the information sometimes
you have to extract it out but
we'll take a look here so uh this is a
way of showing matplotlib
in line i don't think we have to run it
here but i have it in here anyway
and so what it's going to do is it's
going to show us the image
right so it's going to print us the
image and it's going to grab whatever
caption is returns to see how there's
captions
so we're going to iterate through the
captions it's going to give us a
confidence score saying
it thinks it's this so let's see what it
comes out with
okay and so here it says brent spider
spiner looking at a camera so that is
the actor who plays data on star trek
as a confidence score of 57.45 percent
even though it's a hundred percent
correct
uh they probably don't know contextual
things like um uh in the sense of like
pop culture like they don't know
probably star trek characters but
they're going to be able to identify
celebrities because it's in their
database so that is um
uh the first introduction to computer
computer vision there but the key things
you want to remember here is that we use
this describe in image stream
uh and that we get this confidence score
and we get this contextual information
okay and so that's the first one we'll
move on to maybe custom vision next
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at custom
vision so we can do some
classification and object detection so
the thing is is that it's possible it's
possible to
launch custom vision through the
marketplace so if we go we're not going
to do it this way
if you type in custom vision it never
shows up here but if you go to the
marketplace here
and type in custom vision
and you go here you can create it this
way but the way i like to do it i think
it's
a lot easier to do is we'll go up the
top here and type in customvision.ai and
you'll come to this website
and what you'll do is go ahead and sign
in it's going to connect to your azure
account
and once you're in you can go ahead here
and create a new project so the first
one here is i'm just going to call this
the star trek crew
we're going to use this to identify
different star trek members we'll go
down here
and we haven't yet created a resource so
we'll go create new
my custom vision resource
we'll drop this down we'll put this in
our cog services
uh we'll go stick with um us west as
much as we can here
we have fo and so fo is blocked out for
me so just choose so i think f o is the
free tier but i don't get it
and um once we're back here we'll go
down below and choose our standard and
we're going to have a lot of options
here so we have between classification
and object detection so classification
is when you have an image and you just
want to say what
what is this image right and so we have
two modes where we can say
let's apply multiple labels so let's say
there were two people in the photo
or whether there was a dog in cabin i
think this example is a dog and a cat
or you just have a single class where
it's like what is the one thing that is
in this photo it can only be of one of
the particular categories
this is the one we're going to do
multi-class we have a bunch of different
domains here and if you want to
you can go ahead and read about all the
different domains and their
best use case but we're going to stick
with a2 and this is optimized for
so that's faster right and that's really
good for our demo
so we're going to choose general a2 i'm
going to go ahead and create this
project
and so now what we need to do is start
labeling our
our our content so um what we'll do is i
just want to go ahead and create the
tags ahead of time so let's say wharf
we'll have data and we'll have crusher
and now what we'll do is we'll go ahead
and upload those images so you know we
uploaded the jupyter notebook but it was
totally not necessary so here is data
because we're going to do it all through
here and we'll just apply the data tag
to them all at once which saves us a lot
of time i
love that we'll upload now uh
wharf and i don't want to upload them
all i have this one quick test image
we're going to use to make sure that
this works correctly
and i'm going to choose wharf
and then we'll go ahead and add beverly
there she is beverly crusher
okay so we have all our images in i
don't know how this one got in here but
it's under warf it works out totally
fine
so what i want to do
is uh go ahead and train this model
because they're all labeled so we have a
ground truth
and we'll let it go ahead and train so
we'll go and press train
and we have two options quick training
or advanced training advanced training
where we can increase the time for
better accuracy
but honestly uh we just want to do quick
training so i'll go ahead and do quick
training
and it's going to start its iterative
process notice on the left hand side we
have probability threshold
the minimum probability score for a
prediction to be valid when calculate
calculating precision and recall so we
uh
the thing is is that if it doesn't at
least meet that requirements it will
quit out
and if it gets above that then it might
quit out early just because it's good
enough okay
so training doesn't take too long it
might take five to ten minutes i can't
remember how long it takes but uh
what i'll do is i'll see you back here
in a moment okay all right so after
waiting a short little while here
it looks like our results are done we
get a hundred percent um match here so
these are our evaluation metrics to say
whether
uh the model was uh uh achieved its
actual goal or not
so we have precision recall and i
believe this
is average precision and so it says that
it did a really
good job so that means that it should
have no problem um
matching up an image so in the top right
corner we have this button that's called
quick test and this is going to give us
the opportunity to
uh quickly test these so what we'll do
is browse our files locally here
and actually i'm going to go to uh yeah
we'll go here
and we have wharf and so i have this
quick image here
we'll test and we'll see if it actually
matches up to be worf
and it says 98.7 warps that's pretty
good i also have some additional images
here i just put into the repo
to test again so we'll see what it
matches up because i thought it'd be
interesting to do something that
is not necessarily uh them but it's
something pretty close to
um you know it's pretty close to what
those are okay
so we'll go to crew here and first we'll
try hugh
okay and hugh is the borg so he's kind
of like an android and so we can see he
mostly matches the data so that's pretty
good
uh we'll give another one go martok is a
klingon so he should be matched up to
wharf
very strong match to wharf that's pretty
good and then uh pulaski she is a doctor
and female so she should get matched up
to
beverly crusher and she does so this
works out pretty darn
well uh and i hadn't even tried that so
it's pretty exciting so
now let's say we want to uh go ahead and
uh well if we wanted to
um make predictions we could do them in
bulk here
um i believe that you could do them in
bulk but anyway
yeah i guess i always thought this was
like i could have swore yeah if we
didn't have these images before i think
that it actually has an upload option
it's probably just a quick test
so i'm a bit confused there but anyway
so now that this is ready what we can do
is go ahead and publish it
so that it is publicly accessible so
we'll just say here
crew model okay and we'll drop that down
say publish
and once it's published now we have this
uh public reality so this is an end
point that we can go hit pragmatically
uh i'm not going to do that i mean we
could use postman to do that
um but my point is is that we've
basically figured it out
for um classification so now that we've
done classification
let's go back here to uh the vision here
let's now let's go ahead and do
object detection okay
[Music]
all right so we're still in custom
vision let's go ahead and try out object
detection so object detection is when
you can identify
uh particular items in a scene um and so
this one's going to be com badge that's
what we're going to call it because
we're going to try to detect combat we
have
more domains here we're going to stick
with the general a1
and we'll go ahead and create this
project here
and so what we need to do is add a bunch
of images i'm going to go ahead and
create our tag which is going to be
called com badge
you can look for multiple different
kinds of labels but then you need a lot
of
images so we're just going to keep it
simple and have that there
i'm going to go ahead and add some
images and we're going to go back
a couple steps here into our objects and
here i have a bunch of photos and we
need exactly 15 to train so we got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14
15 16 and so i threw an additional image
in here this is the badge test so we'll
leave that out
and we'll see if that picks up really
well and
yeah we got them all here and so we'll
go ahead and upload those
and we'll hit upload files
okay and we'll say
done and we can now begin to label so
we'll click into here and what i want to
do if you hover over it should start
detecting things
if it doesn't you can click and drag
we'll click this one they're all com
badges so we're not going to tag
anything else here okay
so go here hover over is it going to
give me the combat no so i'm just direct
clicking and dragging to get it
okay okay did we get this com badge yes
do we get this one yep
it's as simple as that
okay it doesn't always get it but uh
most cases it does
okay didn't get that one so we'll just
drag it out
okay it's not getting that one
it's interesting like that one's pretty
clear but uh it's interesting what it
picks out and what does what does not
grab a so
it's not getting this one probably
because the photo doesn't have enough
contrast
and this one has a lot hoping that that
gives us more data to work with here
yeah i think the higher the contrast
it's easier for it to uh
detect those it's not getting that one
it's not good in that one okay there we
go
yes there are a lot i know i have some
of these ones that are packed but
there's only like three photos that are
like this
yeah they have badges but they're
slightly different so we're going to
leave those out
oops i think it actually had that one
but we'll just tag it anyway
and hopefully this will be worth the uh
the effort here
there we go
i think that was the last one okay great
so we have all of our tagged photos and
what we can do is go ahead and train the
model
same option quick training advanced
training we're going to do a quick
training here
and notice that the options are slightly
different we have probably threshold
and then we have overlap threshold so
the minimum percentage of overlap
between predictive bounding boxes and
ground truth boxes to be considered for
correct prediction
so i'll see you back here when it is
done all right so after waiting a little
bit a while here it looks like um
it's done it's trained and so
precision's at 75 percent so precision
the number will tell you if a tag is
predicted
by your model how likely that it's
likely to be so how likely did a guest
write then you have recall so
the number will tell you out of the tags
which should be predicted correctly what
percentage does your model correctly
find so we have a hundred percent
uh and then you have mean average
precision this number will tell you the
overall object detector performance
across
all the tags okay so
what we'll do is we'll go ahead and do a
quick test on this model
and we'll see how it does i can't
remember if i actually even ran this so
it'll be curious to see
the first one here um it's not as
clearly visible it's part of their
uniform so i'm not expecting to pick it
up but we'll see what it does it picks
up
pretty much all of them the exception
this one is definitely not a com badge
but
that's okay only show suggests obviously
the probabilities above the selected
threshold
so if we increase it let's bring it down
a bit so there it kind of improves it
um if we move it around back and forth
okay
so i imagined via the api we could
choose that let's go look at our other
sample image here um
i'm not seeing it
uh where did i save it let me just
double check make sure that it's in the
correct directory here okay yeah i saved
it to the wrong place just a moment
um i will place it
just call that badge test two one second
okay and so i'll just browse here again
and so here we have another one see if
it picks up the badge right here there
we go so
looks like it works so uh yeah i guess
custom vision is uh pretty easy to use
and
uh pretty darn good so what we'll do is
close this off and make our way back to
our jupiter
labs to move on to
our our next uh lab here okay
[Music]
all right so let's move on to the face
service so just go ahead and double
click there on the left hand side and
what we'll do is work our way from the
top so the first thing we need to do
is make sure that we have the computer
vision installed so
the face service is part of the computer
vision api
and once that is done we'll go ahead and
do our imports
very similar to the last one but here
we're using the face client we're still
using the
cognitive service credentials we will
populate our keys
we make the face client and authenticate
and we're going to use the same image we
used
prior with our computer vision so the
data went there and we'll go ahead
and print out the results and so we get
an object back so it's not very clear
what it is but
here if we hit show okay here it's data
and it's identifying the face ids and
going through this code so we're just
saying open the image
we're going to set up our figure for
plotting
it's going to say well how many faces
did it detect in the photo and so
here it says detected one face it will
iterate through it
and then we'll create a bounding box
around the images we can do that because
it returns back the face
rectangle so we got a top left right etc
and we will draw that wrangle on top so
we have magenta i could change it to
like
three if i wanted to i don't know what
the other colors are so i'm not even
going to try but yeah there it is
and then we annotate with the face id
that's the unique identifier for the
face
and then we show the image okay so
that's one and then if we wanted to get
more detailed information like
attributes such as
age emotion makeup or gender
this resolution image wasn't large
enough so i had to find a different
image
and and do that so that's one thing you
need to know as if it's not large enough
it won't process it so we're just
loading data large
very similar process but it is
the same thing detect with stream but
now we're passing in
return face attributes and so here we're
saying the attributes we want
and there's that list and we went
through it in the lecture content and so
here
we'll go ahead and run this and so we're
getting more information so that magenta
line is a bit hard to see i'm just going
to increase that to three
okay still really hard to see but that's
okay so
approximate age 44 i think the actor was
a bit younger than that
uh data technically is male presenting
but
he's an android so he doesn't
necessarily have a gender i suppose
he actually is wearing a lot of makeup
but all it detects is
i guess it's only particular on the lips
and the eyes so it says he doesn't have
makeup so maybe there's like color
you know like eyeshadow stuff maybe
would detect that in terms of
uh personality i like how it's he's a
zero zero two points
percent uh sad but he's neutral right uh
so just going through the code here very
quickly so again it's the number of
faces so it detected one face
uh and then we draw a bounding box
around the face
for the detected attributes it's uh
returned back in
the data here so we just say get the
phase attributes turn it into a
dictionary
and then we can just uh get those values
and
iterate over it so that's as complicated
as it is
and so there we go
[Music]
all right so we're on to uh our next
cognitive service let's take a look at
form recognizer
all right and so form recognizer it
tries to
identify um like forums and turns them
into readable things
and so they have one for uh receipts in
particular so the top
finally we're not using um the computer
uh computer vision we actually have a
different one so this one's azure ai
form recognizer so we'll run that there
but this one in particular
isn't up to date in terms of using it
like um
notice all the other ones they're using
uh the
cognitive service credentials so for
this we actually had to use the azure
key credential which was annoying i
tried to use the other one to be
consistent
but i i couldn't use it okay so what
we'll do is run our keys like before
we have a client very similar process
and this time we actually have a receipt
and so
we have begin recognize the receipt so
it's going to analyze the receipt
information
and then it's what it's going to do is
show us the image okay just so we have a
reference to look at
now the image isn't actually yellow it's
a white background i don't know why when
it renders out here it does that but
that's just what happens
and it even obscures the server name i
don't know why
but anyway if we go down below
this has returned results up here right
so we got our results
and so if we just print out uh the
results here we can see we get a
recognized form back we get
fields and some additional things and if
we go into the
uh the fields itself we see there's a
lot more information if you can make out
like here it says merchant phone number
form field label value and there's the
number 512
707 so for these things here like
um the receipts
maybe we can just find the api quickly
here it has predefined
fields i'm not sure um
yeah business card etc um
like if we just type in merchant
i'm just trying to see if there's a big
old list here it's not really showing us
a full list but these are
our predefined um things that are
returned right so they've
defined those uh maybe it's over here
there we go so these are the predefined
ones that extracts out so we have
uh receipt type merchant name etc etc
and so if we go back to here you can see
um i i have the field called merchant
name so we hit
there it says alamo draft cinema let's
say we want to try to get that balance
maybe we can try to figure out which one
it is
i never ran this myself when i made it
so we'll see what it is
but here it has total price what's
interesting is that these
this is a space so it's kind of unusual
you think it'd be together but let's see
if that
works okay doesn't like that
maybe that's just a typo on their part
okay so we get none
uh let's try price
see what it picks up nope nothing um
we know that the phone number is there
so we'll give the phone number
there we go so you know it's an okay
service
but uh you know uh you know your your
mileage will vary based on what you do
there maybe we could try total
because that makes more sense right uh
yeah there we go okay great so yeah it
is pulling out the information um
and so that's pretty much all you need
to know about that service there okay
[Music]
let's take a look at some of our ocr
capabilities here and i believe that's
in computer vision so we'll go ahead and
open that up
at the top here we'll install computer
vision as we did before
very similar to the other computer
vision tasks but this time we have
a couple of ones here that i'll explain
that as we go through here we'll load
our keys
we'll do our credentials we'll load the
client
okay and then we have this function here
called printed text
so what this function is going to do is
it's going to
print out the results of whatever text
it processes okay
so the idea is that we're going to feed
in an image
and it's going to give us back out the
text for the image so we'll run
this function and i have two different
images because i actually ran on the
first one and the results were terrible
and so
i got a second image and it was a bit
better okay so we'll go ahead and run
this it's going to show us the image
okay and so this is the photo it was
supposed to extract out star trek the
next generation but
because of the artifacts and size of the
image we get back uh
not english okay and so you know
maybe a high resolution image it would
have a better a better time there
but that is what we got back okay
so let's go take a look at our second
image and see how it did
and this one i'm surprised it actually
extracts out a lot more information
you can see it really has a hard time
with the star trek font but we get deep
space nine
nana visitor tells all life death some
errors here so it's not perfect
um but you know you can see that it does
something here
now there is the this is like for ocr
where we have like first very simple
images and text this is where we use the
recognized printed text in stream
but if we're doing this for larger
amounts of text and we want to do this
uh i want this analyze asynchronously
then we want to use the read api and
it's a little bit more involved
so what we'll do here is load a
different image and this is a script
we'll look at the image here in a moment
but here we read and stream and we
create these operations
okay and what it will do is it will
asynchronous asynchronously
send all the information over okay uh so
i think this is supposed to be results
here
minor typo and um
we will go ahead and give that a run
okay and so here you can see it's
extracting up the image if we want to
uh see this image i thought i uh i
thought i showed this image here but i
guess i don't
yeah it's this plot image here to show
us the image
uh path
it's up here
it doesn't want to show us it's funny
because this one up here showing us no
problem right
um well i can just show you the image
it's not a big deal
but i'm not sure why it's not showing up
here today
if we go to our assets here
i go to ocr
i'm just going to open this up it's
opening up in photoshop and so this is
what it's transcribing okay
so this is a thing this is like a guide
to star trek where they
talk about like you know what what makes
star trek star trek
so just looking here it's actually
pretty darn good okay but like read api
is a lot more
efficient because it can work uh um
asynchronously and so when you have a
lot of text that's what you want to do
okay
and like it's feeding in each individual
line right so that it can be more
effective that way
um so let's go look at some handwritten
stuff so just in case the image doesn't
pop up we'll go ahead and open this one
and so this is a a handwritten note that
uh
william shatner wrote to a fan of star
trek
and it's basically incomprehensible i
don't know if you can read that here but
see was very something he was
something hospital and healthy was
something he was something i can't even
read it
okay so let's see what uh the machine
thinks here
and uh it says image path yeah it's
called path let's just change that out
go ahead and run that and run that there
and we'll go ahead and run it and here
we get the image so
uh boner us very sick he was the
hospital his
beauty was etc beat nobody lost his
family knew captain halden
so reads better than how i could read it
honestly like it is
it's really hard right like if you
looked at this
like that looks like difficult
was beady healthy i could see why it's
guessing like that right dying
that looks like dying to me you know
what i mean so
it's just poorly hand hand written but i
mean it's pretty good for what it is so
uh yeah there you go
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at
another cognitive service here and this
one is text
analysis and so what we'll do is install
the azure cognitive services
language text analytics here so go ahead
and hit
run all right and once that's
installed this one actually is using the
cognitive services credentials so it's a
little bit more
standard with our other ones here we'll
go ahead and run that there
we'll make our credentials load our
clients
and this one what we're going to do is
try to determine sentiment and
understand why people like a particular
movie or not
so i've loaded a bunch of reviews um
they
are again i can show you the data if it
helps
and so i'm just trying to find my right
folder here and so if we go back
look our movie reviews here's like a
review someone wrote
first contact just works it works as a
rousing chapter in the star trek to
lesser
it works as a mainstream entertainment
so different reviews for star trek first
contact which was a
very popular movie back in the day so
what we'll do is we will
load the reviews so it's just iterating
through the text files and showing us
what the reviews are so here we can see
all the written text
i had a lot of trouble getting the last
one to display but it does get loaded in
and so here we're using the the
text analysis to show us uh key phrases
because maybe that would give us an
indicator
and so that's the object back but maybe
that would give us an indicator as to
like what people are
saying as important things so here we
see borg ship enterprise smaller ship
escapes
neutral zone travels contact damage
co-writer beautiful mind sophisticated
science fiction
best wales leonard nimoy okay
wealth of unrealized potential filmmaker
john franks
okay so very interesting stuff as it
here borg ship again you're seeing borg
ship a lot
so that is kind of key phrases let's go
get uh cust or
customer sentiment or how people felt
about it did they like it or not
and so here we just call sentiment and
what we'll do is if it's uh
above five then it's positive and it's
below five then it's a negative review
i think most people uh thought it was a
very good film
so this one says it's pretty low nine so
let's go take a look at that one
it wasn't actually showing rendered
there so maybe we'll have to open it up
manually
see if that's actually accurate it's
empty so there you go
i guess we had a blank one in there i
must have forgot to paste it in but
that's okay
that's a good indicator that uh you know
that's what happens if you don't have it
so let's look at number one then which
is
uh well actually this one is nine this
is zero four
this one here is eight so open up eight
when the board launched on earth the
enterprise is sent to the neutral zone
etc etc however a smaller ship escapes
travel the enterprise falls back
um meanwhile the survivors so like this
is a synopsis it doesn't say whether
they like it or they don't but it was
just
before i guess so there's nothing
positive about it right
um if we look at one that was this one's
pretty low
which is no no it's not it's one
so it seems like this person probably
really liked it
or no i guess that's actually pretty low
because it's one it's not nine
nine is very high let's take a look at
this one review number two
uh if we go up here the taco has
improved the story almost during the
show but there's a wealth of unrealized
potential so that's a fair
one saying that maybe they don't like it
as much i don't know if they give it two
stars
right we could probably actually
correlate it with the actual results
because i did get these off of imdb and
run tomatoes but uh
yeah there you go that is text analysis
[Music]
all right so now we're on to q a maker
and so
we're not going to need to do anything
pragmatically because q a maker
is all about no code or low code to
build out a questions and answers uh
bot service so what we'll do is go all
the way up here and i want you to type
in qnmaker.ai because
as far as i'm aware of it's not
accessible through the portal
sometimes you can find these things
again if we go to the marketplace
i'm just curious i'm gonna just take a
look here really quickly
uh whenever it decides to log us in here
okay great so i'll go over to
marketplace
and probably if we type in q a maybe
we'd do something here q
a
yep so we go here um
give it a second here seems like azure
is a little bit slow
right now
it's usually varies fast but uh you know
the service varies
well it's not loading for me right now
but that's okay because we're not going
to do it that way anyway
um so again go to q a maker
dot ai and what i want you to do is go
all in the top of the right corner and
we'll hit sign in
and what we'll be doing is connecting
via our single sign-on with our account
so it already knows i have an account
there
i'm going to give it a moment here and
i'm going to go ahead
and just give it a second
there we go so it says i don't have any
um knowledge base which is true so let's
go ahead and create ourselves a new
knowledge base
and here we have the option between
stable and preview i'm going to stick
with stable because i don't know what's
in preview
i'm pretty happy with that and so we
need to connect uh q a service
uh q a service to our knowledge base
and so back over here in azure actually
i guess we do have to make one now that
i remember we actually have to create a
q a maker service
so i'll go down here and put this under
my cog services we'll say
my um q and a
q and a service might complain about the
name
uh yep so i'll just put some numbers
here
we'll pick uh free tier sounds good so
go free when i actually get the option
that's what i will choose
um down below we'll choose free again
usb sounds great to me
uh it generates out the name it's the
same name as here so that's fine
uh we don't need app inside so i'm going
to leave it enabled because i think it
changes it to standard or s0
when you do not have it enabled
unusually
and so we will create our q a maker
service
give it a moment here it says
i remember it will say like even if you
try you might have to wait 10 minutes
for it to create the service so even
though
even after it's provisioned uh it'll
take some time so what we should do
is prepare our doc because it can take
in a variety of different files
and i just want to show you here that
the q a they have a whole paper here
formatting the guidelines
and basically it's pretty smart about
knowing where headings and
answers is so for unstructured data we
just have a heading and we have some
text so let's write some things in here
that we can think of
since we're all about certification we
should write some stuff here so
how many aws certifications are there
i believe right now there are four uh 11
uh aws certifications okay
and maybe if we use our headings here
this would probably be a good idea here
yeah
okay another one could be
um how many fundamental
azure certifications are there
and uh we'll give this a heading we'll
say um
there are three azure
i think there's three there's other ones
right like uh
power platform stuff but just being
azure specific there are three
azure uh fundamental
certifications certification so we have
um the dp900
the ai 900 um the az 900 i guess there's
four there's the sc900 right so there
are four
okay
we'll say which is the hardest
um azure associate azure association
certification
and uh what we'll say here is i think
i mean it's my in my opinion is it's the
azure administrator
that's some background noise there
that's why i was a bit positive there
but the azure minister az104
i would say that's the hardest which
is harder
the aws or azure certifications
i'd say azure certifications
are harder because they
check exact steps
for implementation
where aws focuses on
concepts okay so we have a bit of a
knowledge base here so i'll save it and
assuming that this is ready because we
need a little bit time to put this
together
we'll go back to today can hit a refresh
here
give it a moment drop it down
choose our service
and uh notice here that we have chit
chat extraction and only extraction
we're gonna do chit chat
i will say uh my or this will be uh the
reference name if you change anytime
this would be like uh
certification q a
and so here we want to populate so we'll
go to files here i'm going to go to my
desktop
and here it is i'll open it
we will choose professional tone go
ahead and create that
and so i'll see you back here in a
moment all right so after waiting a
short little time here
it loaded in our data so you can see
that it figured out which is the
question which is the answer
and also has a bunch of defaults so here
if somebody was at
something very silly like can you cry
i'll say i don't have a body
it has a lot of information preloaded
for us which is really nice if we want
to go ahead and test this
we could go and say um we'll go here and
then we'll write in
we say like hello
i say boring
this is good morning okay so we'll say
how many uh certifications are there
we didn't say aws but let's just see
what happens
and so it kind of infer even though we
didn't say aws in particular
so and notice that there's aws and azure
so how many fundamental azure
certifications things like that and so
it
chose aws so it's not like the perfect
service but it's pretty good
i wonder what would happen if we um
placed in
uh one that's like azure i don't know
how many azure search there are we'll
just say like there's 11 12. i can never
remember they're always adding more
but uh i want to close this here there
we go so let's just go add a new
key pair here and we'll say how many
azure
certification
[Music]
are there i should have said
certifications i'll probably just set
one moment so there there are
12 azure certifications
who knows how many they have they give
like 14 or something say like
between 11 and 14.
they just add them they just update them
too frequently i can't keep track
so we'll go here and we'll just say
certifications
and we will save and retrain so we'll
just wait here a moment
great and so now we'll go ahead and test
this again so we'll say
how many certifications
are there
let's see it's pulling the first answer
if i say azure
let's see if it gets the right one here
how many azure certifications are there
okay so you know uh maybe you'd have to
say
you'd have to have a generic one for
that match so if we go back here and we
say
how many certifications are there
you could say uh you know like uh
which certification
uh uh which cert cloud service provider
okay we got aws azure
uh fall prompt you can use guides
through conversational flow prompts are
used to link q a pairs and can be
displayed
um i haven't used this yet but i mean it
sounds like something that's pretty good
um because there is multi-turn in this
so the idea is that if you had to go
through multiple steps you could
absolutely do that
um we could try this a little bit here
um follow prompt you can use to guide
use convert props are used to link q and
a pairs together
text or button for suggested action oh
okay so maybe we just do like aws
link to q a and then so search an
existing q a or create a new one
um so we'd say like how many aws
okay we're typing it in context only
this follows up will not be understood
out of the context flow
sure because it should be within context
right
and here we can do another one we say
like um
azure we'll say
how many azure
contacts only oops that
got away from me there
we'll save that and what we'll do is
save and train
so go back here and we'll say how many
uh certifications are there
enter so we have to choose aws
and so there we go so we got something
that works pretty good there since i'm
happy with it we can go ahead and go and
publish that so let's say publish now
that it's published we could use postman
or curl to
trigger it but what i want to do is
create a bot because with azure bot
services then we can actually utilize it
um with other integrations right it's a
great way to
use your bot or to actually host your
bot so we'll go over here
it'll link it over if you don't click it
it doesn't preload it in so it's kind of
a pain if you lose it you have to go
back there and click it again but
let's just say certification q
and a and we will look through here so
i'm going to go with free premium
messages 10k
1k premium message units messages you
i'm kind of confused by the pricing but
f0 usually means free so that's what i'm
going to go for that sdk or node.js i'm
going to use node.js not that we're
going to do anything there with it
go ahead and create that
and i don't think this takes too long
we'll see here
and let me just go ahead and click on
that there
i'll just wait here but i'll see you
back here in a moment all right so after
waiting
i don't know about five minutes there it
looks like our bot service is deployed
we'll go to that
resource there you can download the bot
source code actually i never did this
so i don't know what it looks like so be
curious to see this
um just to see what the code is i assume
that because we chose node.js
it would give us that is the default
there so download just as quick as you
bought creating the source zip
not sure how long this takes might be
regretting clicking on that but uh
what we'll do is we'll go on the left
hand side here to channels
because i just want to show uh here yeah
i don't
thought didn't download uh we'll try
here in a second but
um what we'll do is we'll go back oop
profile
uh unspecified bot we talking about
yeah maybe it needs some time
so you know maybe we'll just give the
bot a little bit of time here i'm not
sure why it's giving us a hard time
because this bot is definitely deployed
if we go over to our bots
right bot services it is here
sometimes there's like latency you know
with uh
azure and oh there we go okay so it
works now fine right and so i want to
show you that there's different channels
and these are just easy ways to
integrate your bot in different services
so
whether you wanted to use it with alexa
group me
skype telephony twilio skype
business apparently they don't have that
anymore because i get salt teams now
right
uh kik which i don't know people still
use that slack
which is that discord telegram facebook
email
um that's kind of cool but teams teams
is a really good one i use teams uh
there's a
direct line channel i don't know what
that means and there's web chat which is
just
having like an embed code so if we go
over we can go and test it over here
just start testing our web chat and so
it's the same thing as before but we
just say things like uh
how many certifications are there
select azure and get a clear answer back
we'll go back up to our overview let's
try to see if we can download that code
again i was kind of curious
what that looks like
if it will download
must be a lot of code eh
there we go so now we can hit download
and so there is the code i'm going to go
ahead and open that up
so yeah i guess when we chose javascript
that made a lot more sense
let's give it a little peek here i'm
just going to
drop this on my desktop here so let's
make a new folder here and call this
uh bot code okay i know you can't see
what i'm doing here but uh
let's go here and dr
double click into here and then just
drag that code on in
and then what we can do is open this up
in vs code i should have vs code running
somewhere around here
i'm just going to go ahead and open that
i'm off screen here i'll just show you
my screen in a moment
say show code oops
file open folder
bot code okay
and we'll come all the way back here and
so we've got a lot of code here
never looked at this before but you know
i'm a pretty good uh programmer so it's
not too hard for me to understand
um so looks like you got api requests
things like that
i guess it would just be like if you
needed to integrate into your
application then it kind of shows you
all the code there
i'm just trying to see our dialogue
choices
uh nothing super exciting
okay you know when i go and make the um
was it the ai or the ai 100 whatever the
data scientist course is i'm sure i'll
be a lot more
thorough here but i was just curious as
to what that looks like now if we wanted
to
have an easy integration uh we can get
an embed code for this so if we go back
to our channels
i believe uh we can go
and say edit
ah yes so here we have a code so what
i'll do is go back to jupiter labs
i'm just gonna go make a new empty
notebook so we'll just go up here and
say notebook
and this can be for our q a it doesn't
really matter what kernel
we'll say q and a maker
just show like if you wanted a very very
simple way of integrating your bot
um we would go back over to
wherever it is here ah here we are i'm
gonna go ahead and copy this iframe
i think it's percentage percentage html
so it treats this cell as html
and i don't have any html to render so
we'll place that in there and notice we
have to replace our secret key
so i will go back here and i will show
my key and we will copy that
and we'll paste that key in here
and then we'll run this and i can type
in
here where am i just ask silly things
uh who are you
how many azure certifications
are there well i wonder if i just leave
the are there off let's see if it
figures it out okay cool so
uh yeah i mean that's pretty much it
with q a maker
um so yeah that's great so i think we're
done here and we can move on to checking
out
lewis or l-u-i-s learning understanding
to make a more
robust bot okay
[Music]
all right so we are on to our last
cognitive service and this one is going
to be
lewis or luis depending on how you like
to say it it's l-u-i-s which is language
understanding so you type in l-u-i-s dot
a-i
uh and that's going to bring us up to
this external website still part of
azure just has its own domain and so
here we'll choose our subscription
and we have no author authoring source
so i guess we'll have to go ahead and
create one ourselves
so go down here and we'll choose my
cognitive services
azure resource name so my
auth service or
my cognitive service
create new cognitive service account but
we already have one so
i don't want to make another one right
it should show up here right
or valid in the author authoring region
so it's possible that we're just in the
incorrect region so we might end up
creating two of these and that's totally
fine i don't care it's as long as we get
this work in here because we're going to
delete
everything at the end anyway and so just
say my cog service
to and we'll say
west u.s because i think that maybe we
didn't choose one of these regions let's
go double check
if we go back to our portal
just the limitations of the service
right so we'll go to
my cog services here i just want to go
cognitive services so just want to see
where this is deployed
and this is in um west u.s
yes i don't know why it's not showing up
there but whatever if that's what it
wants we'll give it what it wants okay
shouldn't give us that much trouble but
hey that's how it goes
and so we have an authority authoring
service i'm going to refresh here and
see if it added a second one
it didn't so all right
that's fine so we'll just say my sample
bot
we'll use english as our culture if
nothing shows up here don't worry
you can choose it later on i remember
the first time i did this it didn't show
up
and so now we have my cog service my
custom vision service we want cog
service
so um
anyway it tells you about schema like
how you make a scheme and
animates talking about like bot action
intent and
example utterance but we're just going
to set up something very simple here so
we're going to create our intent the one
that we always see
is flight booking
so go here and do that and what we want
to do is
write an under in so like uh book me a
flight
to toronto okay
and so if someone were to type that in
then the idea was it would return back
the intent this value and
metadata around it and we could
pragmatically provide code right so
what we need is identity identities and
we can actually just click here and
uh make one here so enter named identity
and we'll just call this location
okay here we have option machine learned
and list if you flip between it
this is like imagine you have a ticket
order and you have these values that can
uh change or you just have a value that
always stays the same like list so
that's our airport
that makes sense we'll do that
if we go over to entities we can see it
here
all right so nothing super exciting
there but what i want to show you
is if we go ahead and um we should
probably add
fight booking should be uh how about
book flight
flight booking fight booking okay so
we'll go ahead and
lose only one we'll go ahead and train
our model
because we don't need to know tons right
we cover a lot in the lecture content
to build a complex spot is more for the
associate level
but now what we can do is go ahead and
test this and we'll say
book me a flight to seattle
okay and notice here it says book flight
we can go inspect it
and we get some additional data so top
scoring so it says how likely that was
the intent
um okay so you get kind of an idea there
there's additional things here it
doesn't really matter
we'll go back here and we'll go ahead
and publish our model
so we can put it into a production slot
you can see we have sentiment analysis
speech priming we don't care about
either of those things
we can go and see where our endpoint is
and so
now we have an endpoint that we can work
with
um so yeah i mean that's pretty much all
you really need to learn about luis
um but uh i think we're all done for
cognitive services so
we're gonna keep around our our notebook
because um we're gonna still use our
jupyter notebook for some other
things but what i want you to do is make
your way over to
your resource groups because if you've
been pretty clean it's all within here
we'll just take a look here so we have
our q a
all of our stuff here i'm just making
sure it's all there and so i'm just
gonna go ahead and
delete this resource group and that
should wipe away
everything okay for the cognitive
services part
all right so we're all good here i'm
just going to go
off and i'll leave this open because
it's always a pain to get back to it and
reopen it but let's make our way back to
the home here
in the azure uh machine learning studio
and now we can actually
explore building up machine learning
pipelines
[Music]
okay so we are on to the ml
follow alongs here so we're gonna learn
how to build some pipelines the first i
think is the easiest would be auto
automated ml or also known as automl the
idea here is it's going to just
um build up the entire pipeline for us
so we don't have to do any thinking we
just say
what kind of model we want to run and
have it to make a prediction so what
we'll do is say new automated ml
and we're going to need a data set so i
don't have one but the nicest thing is
they have these open data sets
so if you click here you'll see there is
a bunch here
and a lot of these you'll come across
quite often not just on azure but other
places like this diabetes
one i've seen it like everywhere okay
uh and so like if we just go click here
maybe we can read a bit more here so
diabetes data set 422 samples with 10
features
ideal for getting started with machine
learning algorithms it's one of the
popular
scikit-learn toy data sets it's probably
where i've seen it before
so it's not showing up there you scroll
on down you can see
the data you notice that it's available
as your notebooks databricks and azure
synapse
the thing is we have these values so age
sex bmi
bp and the y is trying to make a
prediction it's trying to say
what's the likelihood of you having
diabetes or not and so it's not boolean
value so it's not a binary classifier
it's kind of on a
uh well i guess you would you be doing
binary classifications
classification say do you have diabetes
or you can make a prediction to say
what's the likelihood or this value if
you gave another value in there
but um anyway you this is the predicting
value a lot of times
this is x so everything here is x and
this is considered y the actual
prediction
so sometimes it's y and sometimes it's
actually named what it is
but that's just what it is here so we'll
close that off and so we'll choose the
diabetes set
and it will be data set one
and so it will worry about feedback
later so we'll click on sample
diabetes we'll hit next and here it's
going to try to figure out
uh what kind of model that we want we
have to create a new experiment it's a
container to run the model in so just
say
diabetes uh it's my diabetes it sounds a
bit odd but that's what it is the target
column we want to predict
um is seeing the train to predict is the
y
it's usually the y um we don't have a
compute cluster so i'll go ahead and
create a new compute
we have dedicated or low priority
technically we
um it is low priority but i just want
this done a little prior cheaper but
don't get too compute notes
your job may be pre-emptied um i'm going
to say with dedicated for the time being
we're going to stick with cpu
uh if we go with
this it does take about an hour to run
so when i ran the stick about an hour so
if you don't mind it's only going to
cost you 15 cents
but if you want this done a lot sooner
i'm going to try to do something a
little bit more powerful
so i'm just trying to decide here
because if it only takes an hour
uh i might run it on something more
powerful that's 90 cents
that might be overkill because it's not
really deep learning
it's just statistical statistical stuff
so try and large data set
i wouldn't say it's large real-time
inference other latency sensitive ones
um
how about
why is this one i'm just looking here
because this one's 29 so this one's more
expensive
but it has 32 gigabytes of ram this one
is 28
oh 14 gigabytes of ram oh storage so
this one's our highest in the tier again
you can choose this one
you just have to wait a lot longer i
just want to see if it finishes a lot
faster okay without having to go to the
gpu level
because i don't think gpu is going to
help too much here um the computer name
is
my diabetes machine
minimum number nodes you want to
provision if you want dedicated nodes to
set the count here
maximum i guess i just want one node
right
uh we will go ahead and oops uh complete
name must be two 16 characters long
what doesn't is it too long okay there
we go
we'll give it a moment here
yeah it's going to spin up the cluster
so it does take a little bit time to
start this so i'll see you back here
when this is done okay
great so after a short little wait there
it looks like our cluster is running if
we double check here we can go to
compute
i believe that shows up under here under
the compute cluster
so there it is notice it's slightly
different this one shows you
applications and this one is just size
and etc we can click in here see nodes
and
run times we'll go make our way back
here
uh and we'll go ahead and hit next and
notice that i think it actually will
select what it generally thinks it'll
look at your prediction value maybe
sample a bit of it and say okay you
probably want a regression thing so to
predict a continuous numeric values
so the thing is is that if it was a
label like text
or if it was just zero in one it
probably would choose classification
because it's
you saw our our y value is like a number
that was all over the place
it thinks it's regression so i think
that's a good indicator
there so let's go with regression
you know but you might want it as a
binary classifier but uh yeah that's
another story there
so it's uh as soon as we created it it
just started it didn't give us the
option to say hey
i want to start running it uh notice on
this here it's going to do featurization
so that means it's automatically going
to select out features for us which is
what we wanted to do
it's set up to do regression uh we have
some configuration here so training time
is three hours
doesn't mean it's going to train for
three hours but that's i guess it's time
out for it
um you could set a metric uh score
threshold so
it has to meet at least this to be
successful if it's not going to do it
probably would quit out early
cross number val or cross validations
just make sure the data is good you can
see blocked algorithms so tensorflow dnn
tensorflow
linear regression if it was using dnn so
deep learning neural network i would
probably
chose the gpu to see if it would go
faster
look at the primary metric it's
normalized root square
root mean square errors sometimes on the
exam they'll actually ask you like
what's the primary metric for
this thing so it's good to take a look
and see what they actually use for that
i'll probably be sure to highlight that
stuff in the actual lecture content
but this will take some time to run we
have data guard rails it will actually
not populate i guess until we've ran it
so
we'll just let it run and i'll see you
back here when it's done okay
all right so after a very very very long
wait our auto ml job is done it took
60 minutes so using a larger instance
didn't save me any time
i don't know if maybe if i ran a gpu
instance it would be a lot faster i'd be
very curious to try that out but
not something for uh this certification
course
so we go into here and yeah the cheaper
instance was the same amount of time so
it probably just needs gpus
it really depends on the type of models
it's running so we have a bunch of
different algorithms in here
it ran about 42 different models
i thought last time i ran it i saw a lot
more but you can see there's
all kinds of models that it's running
and then it's going to choose the top
candidate so it shows
voting ensemble so ensemble is
we don't cover really in the course
because it gets too much into ml but
ensemble is when you actually use two
different
weaker models and combine the results in
order to
make a more uh powerful ml model okay
so here we'll get some explanation i
tried this before and i didn't get
really good information
so if we go here so like i don't have
anything under model performance so
this tab requires array of predicted
values from the model to be supplied
we didn't supply any so we don't get any
data explorer so select
a cohort of the data that all the data
is with those we
have here um so like here we're seeing
age and i guess it's just giving us an
indicator
about the age information um use the
slider to show
descending feature important select up
to three cohorts to
see the feature important slide by side
okay
so i guess s5 and bmi i don't know what
s5 is we'd have to
look up the data set be a bmi is your
body mass index so that's a clear
indicator as to
what affects whether you have diabetes
or not so that makes sense age doesn't
seem to be a huge factor which is kind
of interesting
individual feature importance we can go
here and just kind of like narrow in and
say okay well why is this outlier over
here and they're like
age 79 right so it's kind of interesting
to see that information so it does give
you some ex
explanation as to to you know why things
are why they are
um over here we have a little bit more
different data this is kind of
interesting model performance
i don't know what i'm looking at but
like here it's over mean squared so it's
that
mean squared calculation there again
okay
so yeah it's something right uh but
anyway the point is is that
uh oh dude that we finally get metrics
so i guess we always had to click there
because that makes more sense
so yeah there's more values here sure
data transformation uh all sorts of data
processing feature engine scaling
techniques and machine learning
algorithm
automl so you know if you were a real
data scientist all this stuff would make
sense to you
um i think just with time it'll it'll
make sense but even
at this point i'm not sure and i don't
care about the model right if you're
building something for real i'm sure
the information becomes a lot more
valuable so
this model is done uh and the idea is
that we can deploy
oops if we go back to the actual uh
models oh because we actually went into
the main so we go back to the
automl here i think you can deploy
any model that you like so then you go
here and deploy this like if you prefer
a different model you could deploy it
if we go into data rails we kind of
skipped over that this is
a way it does automatic featurization so
it's extracting up the feature so
it's how it handles the splitting how it
handles missing features
high cardinality is like if you have too
much data it might have to do
dimensionality reduction so that's just
saying like hey if this is a problem
maybe we would
do some pre-processing or stuff to make
it easier to work with the data
so if we're happy with this we can go
ahead and deploy it
so say deploy
just say infer my diabetes
here we have aks and
azure container instance let's do azure
kubernetes
kubernetes service just because we did
the other one here um
say diabetes
broad maybe
aks diabetes
oh compute name sorry um
one of the inference ones okay so in
order to
deploy this we would have to create our
pipeline i'm not sure if i have enough
in my quota here but let's go give it a
go so i think what it's wanting is one
of these here
uh i think we want this wherever we are
right i'm not sure
where we are if this is u.s east or
west here let's go check
studio
azure machine learning
east us
now i never did this when i was um i
just use usually azure container
instance but
i'm just curious here say next
my diabetes
prod we
will we need to choose some nodes
uh the number of nodes multiplied by the
virtual machines number of cores must be
greater or equal to 12.
okay now again if you're not confident
like if you're concerned about cost you
can just
again watch you don't have to do right
um
this is again a fundamental
certification it's not
super important to get all the hands-on
experience yourself
but i'm just trying to explore this so
we can see right because i
i don't care about cost it's not a big
deal to me on my machine here
uh so probably i don't have
some pool must use a vm sku with more
than two cores and four
gigabytes well what did i choose did i
not choose the right one
i'll try this again
oh i chose three yeah that's fair
um
uh what did it want 12 cores set before
i think
valid parameters more details
because it already exists based on that
name eh two
it's giving us all this trouble a this
one will go ahead and delete you think
like it wouldn't matter like i wouldn't
have to delete it out but that's fine
this one failed now what's the problem
quote exceeded so i can't do it because
i don't i'd have to go make a support
request increase it
so it's not a real big deal um i guess
what we could do
is instead of doing it on aks we just
deployed to container instance if it
will let us
notice i don't have to fill anything
additionally it'll just
deploy i think
great uh and so i guess we'll let that
deploy and
i'll see you back here in a bit okay all
right so i'm back here
checking on out on my or checking up on
my auto ml here so if we go over to
compute
we go to inference clusters we don't
have anything under there if we go
over to our experiments under
our diabetes here
because we did choose to deploy the
model
right we clicked deploy
so it should have created an aci
instance let's make our way over to the
portal
the reason why i might not be showing up
is because i'm just running out of
compute
because again it's a quota thing um
it's not a big deal for us to get it
deployed it's not like we're gonna do
anything with it but uh yeah so we can
see that
we have a container over here and it's
running
so we must be able to uh see if we go to
endpoints here
ah here it is right i was under models
that's my problem uh so pipeline
endpoints that would be something i
i think that if we had deployed our
designer i thought we would have saw it
under there but
here we have our binary pipeline or our
diabetes prod pipeline so if we wanted
to like test data
you know we could pass stuff in here um
i think if we wanted to kind of just
like
see this in action i'm not sure if it's
going to work but we'll give it a go so
if we go into our sample diabetes data
set
and we just explore some of the data we
should be able to kind of select
out some values because i don't know
what these values mean so let's just say
like 36
oops 36 but we already know that bmi is
the major factor here
uh sex is either one or two so we'll say
two
bmi we'll say 25.3
the bp will be ad3
or whatever oops 83 here
s1 160
s2 can be 99.6
345. forty five and five
five point one oh we only we're running
out of metrics here
uh eighty-two what
doesn't give us all of them oh i guess
it does it's up to six
okay so let's go ahead and test that see
what we get and we got a result back 168
so
uh that is uh automl i'll complete there
for you
yeah so there you go
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
the visual designer because it's a great
way to get
started very easily uh with
uh if you don't know what you're doing
and you want something a little bit more
advanced than automl and have some
customization
it's great to start with one of these
samples so let's go ahead and expand it
and see what we have here
we have binary classification with
custom python script
uh tune parameters for binary
classification
multi-class multi-class classification
so letter recognition
text classification all sorts of things
usually binary classification
classification is pretty easy i'm
looking for one that is pretty darn
simple
let's go take a look here so this says
the sample shows how to filter base
features selection to selection features
binary classification so how do
predictors
related to customer relationships using
binary classes how to handle imbalanced
data sets
using smote and modules i'm not really
worried about balancing
customized python script to perform cost
sensitive binary classification
tune parameters so you tune model
primers
best models during the training process
let's go with this one this one seems
okay to me
and so what you can see here is that
it's using a sample data set i believe i
think this is a sample
and if you wanted to see all of them you
could literally drag them out here and
do things with them
i haven't actually uh built one end to
end yet for
uh for this again i don't think it's
like super important for
uh this level of exam but uh this just
shows you that there's a pre-built one
if you
start to get the handle of ml you know
the full pipeline this isn't too
confusing so
at the beginning here we have our
classification data
and then what it's going to do is say
select columns in the data set
so it says exclude column names work
class occupation native country so
it's doing some pre-processing or
excluding that data it might be
interesting to go look at that data set
so if we go over to our data sets tab it
should show up here
i believe maybe because we haven't
uh committed or submitted this we we
can't see that data set yet but we'll
look at it for a moment
then we want to clean our data so here's
saying clean
all the columns so custom substitution
value see if we can see what it's
substituting out
uh it's not saying what so clean missing
data
so i'm not sure what it's cleaning out
there but
because that would suggest that it's
using some kind of custom script
i'm not sure where it is but that's okay
we have split data pretty common to
split your data so you would have a
training and test data set
it's usually really good to randomize it
so you want to randomize it then split
it
um and that's that's just so you get
better results then it has
model hyperparameter tuning so the idea
is that it's going to use ml to figure
out the
the best parameters for tuning over here
we have the two class decision tree
where it's going to do some work there
it's going to score our model and then
it's going to evaluate our model and see
if it's successful so
this is all set up to go so all we got
to do is go to the top here this is
setting wheel here
and we need to choose some type of
compute so i'm going to go here
and we have this one here but i'm going
to go create this for my um
my diabetes one but i'm going to go
ahead and make a new one and we're going
to say
um uh we recommend using a predefined
configuration to quickly set compute
training
this one looks okay
i don't know if it needs two nodes but
uh i guess we can do this one so let's
just say binary
let's just say binary pipeline
okay say
save hopefully it's making a good
suggestion and we'll have to wait for
that to spin up it's going to take a
little bit of time okay so i'll see you
back here
in a moment all right so i got a little
message saying that that
is ready so what we can do i think it
was here my notebook instance no that's
not it but
i definitely saw a pop-up on my screen
uh you might have saw it too you'd have
to be paying close attention for that
but if you go over
um it says that it's it's ready to go so
what i'm going to do is make my way back
over here
we're going to select our compute there
is our binary pipeline i'm going to
select that
and there are some other options we're
going to fill around with that we're
going to go ahead and hit submit
so we need a new experiment so i'm going
to say
binary pipeline we'll hit submit
okay and so this is now running so after
a little while here we're going to start
seeing these go green so it says not
started
we'll give it a moment here so so we can
see some kind of animation
and there it goes it's off to the races
there's not much to do here this is
going to take a while
i don't know i have never ran this one
in particular so i don't know if it's an
hour or 30 minutes
so i'll see you back when it's done
running but yeah it's
it's not that fun to watch but it's cool
that you get a visual uh illustration a
so i'll see you back in a bit
i just wanted to peek in here and take a
look at how it's progressing here and
you can see it's still going and
it's just cleaning the data it's still
not done um i'm not sure how long this
has been running for if we go over to
our experiments and we go into our i
think it's binary pipeline and we look
at the run time
we're about eight minutes in and it
hasn't done a whole lot
so it's still cleaning the data i would
have thought about it be a little bit
faster
i'm kind of used to using like aws and
it goes sagemaker's
uh this doesn't usually take this long
um but i mean it's nice that it's
it's going here but uh yeah so we're
almost out of the pre-processing phase
and we'll be on to the uh the model
tuning okay
all right so after waiting a little
while looks like our pipeline is done
uh so if we make our way over to
experiments and go to binary pipeline we
can see that it took 14 minutes and 22
seconds
uh we can go here and just see some
additional information there's nothing
really else to see we saw all the steps
already ran so you can see them all here
uh okay and so let's say we wanted to
there's nothing under metrics but
um enable metrics log data points
compare these within
across runs we only did a single run so
there's nothing to compare
so let's say we're happy with this and
we want to deploy this model well what
i'm going to do is go back to the
designer
click back here and so now in the top
right corner we can create
our inference pipeline so um
i can't remember submit's going to run
it i don't want to run it again
um i just want to go ahead and create
ourselves a real timer batch pipeline
let's say real time by
pipeline here and what this will do is
it'll actually create a completely
different pipeline so here's
a completely new one but it's
specifically designed to
do deployment okay so this is now one
was for training the model
this one is actually for uh taking in
data and doing inference okay
so what we can do is we can go ahead
and uh just submit this and so we'll put
this
under our binary pipeline here we'll go
ahead and hit submit
and i believe that we need a different
kind of compute here i'm surprised that
it's even running
no i guess it has a compute there so
it's going to run and once it
finishes running then i believe that we
we can go ahead and
deploy it okay so let's just wait for
that to finish all right
all right so after a little while there
we've ran our inferns pipeline and so
uh it's definitely something that is
ready for use the idea is that what we
actually is it's going to go through
this web service input to this web
service output but uh
not so important at this level of
certification
let's see what it looks like to go ahead
and deploy it so
yeah we have the option between a
real-time endpoint and an existing
endpoint
uh we don't have an endpoint yet so
we'll just say binary pipeline
okay and notice we have the option
between oh
it does it wants it lower case binary
pipeline
and we have the option between azure
kubernetes service and azure container
instance
um it's a lot easier to deploy i think
to container instance so
because and we'll be waiting forever for
kubernetes to start up so we're going to
do container instance
we have some options like ssl and things
like that not too worried about it so
we're just going to go ahead and hit
deploy
okay and so that is going to go ahead
and deploy that um so we'll wait for
this real-time inference if we go over
to our compute
it should spin up see this is for
aks so i don't know if it will show up
here i think only i've seen things under
here but i think this will be for
azure kubernetes service and i don't
think we're going to see it show up
under there
however we do not need to be running
this anymore so
we'll go ahead and delete the binary
pipeline because we're not
we don't have it for any use right now
and we might need to free it up for
something else okay
so go ahead and delete it we don't need
it
and uh coming back to our pipeline
our designer here i'm just trying to see
where we can keep track of it
um
well i know it's deploying so waiting
for real-time endpoints so
i'll see you back here when this is done
okay it takes a little bit of time
all right so i think our pipeline is
done if we make our way over to
endpoints there it is the binary
pipeline if we wanted to go ahead there
we could test the data
um and so it actually already has some
pre-loaded data for us
if we hit test it's nice that it fills
it in eh
we get some results back okay so i mean
and then we see like scored labels and
income and score probability so
things like that that is useful so it's
giving back all
all the results but i don't think it has
yeah it doesn't have scored labels and
scored probabilities which is the value
to come back here so there are endpoints
and that is the end
of our exploration with designer okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at what
it would be to actually train a job
programmatically
through the notebook so remember we saw
these samples over here and so we saw
this image classification
mnist and this is a very popular data
set for doing uh computer vision
and these are really great if you want
really learned you should really go
through these and just
read through them because they're
they're probably very very useful uh
i've done a lot of this before so for me
it's it's just it's not too hard to
figure out but i've actually never ran
this one so
let's run it together again we want to
be in uh jupiter lab so
you can go here and click it there or go
to the compute if it's being a bit
finicky and just
look there we'll get a tab open here and
we'll see how this goes so
what i want to do and is just make sure
we're back here i'm going to click into
this one
and we have a few so there's part one
and then we have the deploy stage so
let's look at training
i don't know if we really need to deploy
but we'll give it a read here so in this
tutorial you train an ml model on under
compute resource
resources you'll be training training
and deployment workflow
via the azure machine learning service
in a notebook there's two parts to this
this is using the mnist data set and
scikit learn
and with azure machine learning probably
sdk it's a popular data set with 70 000
grayscale images
each image is hand written digits of 28
times by 28 times pixels representing
numbers from zero to nine the goal is to
create multi-class classifier
to define the digits in a given image
that represents
so we're going to learn a few things
here but let's just jump into it
uh so the first thing is that we need to
import our packages
so here uh it does that map plot lib
inlines just make sure that when we
print things that we visually see them
we're going to need numpy and then
matplotlib itself
the azure ml core and then we're going
to import a workspace since we'll need
one there
and then i guess it just checks the
version making sure if we have the right
version here okay so this is 1.28
0. it's pretty common even this in aws
they'll have like a script in here to
update it in case it is out of date
i'm surprised it didn't include it in
here but that's okay we'll scroll on
down and by the way we're using python
3.6
azure ml if this is the future you know
they might retire the old one you're
using 3.8 but
you know it should generally work if
it's in their sample data set i assume
they try to maintain that okay
so connect to a workspace so create a
workspace object from an existing
workspace
uh reads the file config.json so what
we'll do is go run that i assume it's
kind of like a session
and so here it says it's figured found
our workplace
so really it's just it's not creating a
workspace it's just returning
the existing one so that we have it as a
variable here create an experiment so
that's pretty clear we saw experiments
in the automl and the designer
and so we'll just hit run there
okay so we named it core ml
and we said experiment i wonder if it
actually created one yet let's go over
to experiment and see if it's there
so it is there cool that was fast i
thought it would like print something
out but it didn't do anything there
so create or attach an existing compute
resource by using azure machine compute
a managed service data scientists et
cetera et cetera
yada yada so create a compute uh
creation of a compute takes about five
minutes
so let's see what it's trying to create
so we have some environment variables
that wants to load in i'm not sure how
these are getting in here
i'm not sure where environment variables
are set in
jupiter or even how they get feeded in
but apparently they're somewhere
but we have it doesn't matter because
these are defaulting so here's a cpu
cluster
0 and 4. it's going to use a standard
d2v2 that is the cheapest one that we
can run
i kind of want something a little bit
more powerful just for myself
just because i want this to be done a
lot sooner but again you know if you
don't have a lot of money just stick
with what's there okay
so and this is cpu cluster so if we go
here
i just want to see what our options are
not sure why it's not showing us options
here
you don't have enough quota for the
following vm sizes so it probably
it's because i'm running more than one
vm right now
yes i've said i've hit my quota okay so
like i probably have to request for
mower
um so i think this is the one
i'm using
what's the difference here this standard
dv2 vcpus
it's the same one right so request quote
increase
i don't know if this is instant or not
i'd have to make a support ticket oh
that's going to take too long
so the thing is is that uh because the
reason is is that i'm running the automl
and the design and the designer in the
background here trying to
create all the workshops or the uh the
follow alongs at the same time but
what i'll do is i'll just come back and
when i'm not running one of those other
ones then i will uh
i'll come back here and continue on but
uh we're just here at the step
we want to create a a new computer okay
all right so i'm back and i freed up one
of my compute instances if i go over
here now i just have uh the one
uh cluster instance for my automl
but what we'll do here is again just
read through this so this will create a
cpu cluster
0 to 4 nodes standard d2 v2 i guess
we'll just stick with what what is here
just reading through here it looks like
it tries to find the compute target
it's going to provision it it will
create the cluster
call pool for minimum numbers of nodes
for specific time so wait for completion
so
we'll go ahead and hit play and so
that's going to
go and create us a new cluster so we're
just going to have to wait a little
while here for it to create about five
minutes and i'll see you back here in a
moment
all right so uh the cluster started up
if we go back over here we can see that
it's confirmed i don't know why
it was so quick but uh it went pretty
quickly here
so we're on the next section here
explore the data so download the mnist
data set display some sample images
so it's just talking about it being the
open data set the code retrieves in the
file data set object which is a sub
class of data set file data set
references a single or multiple files of
any format in your data store
the class provides you with the ability
to download or mount files to your
computer by creating a reference to the
data source location
additionally you register the data set
to your workspace for easy retrieval
during training there's a bit more how
to's but we'll give it a good read here
so we have the open data set
mnist it's kind of nice that they have
that reference there
so we have a data folder we make the
directory we are getting the data set
we download it and then we are
registering it so let's go ahead and run
that not sure how fast that is shouldn't
take too
long as it's running we'll go over here
left hand side
refresh and we'll see if it appears
um not as of yet
there it is go into here maybe
explore the data i'm not sure how it
would look like because these are all
images right
yeah so they're in you byte gz so
they're in compressed files we're not
going to be able to see within them but
they're definitely there we know they're
there so that that is now registered
into our
our data set uh display some sample
images so
load the compressed into files into
numpy
then use matplotlib plot 30 random
images from the data
set from above note the step requires
load data function it's included in the
utils pi
this file is included in the sample
folder we have it over here we just
double click
very simple file to load data and we'll
go ahead and run that
and it's pretty pretty simple here
uh so load data x train x test
are we setting up our training and
testing data here it kind of looks like
it because it says
train and test data that's when we
usually see that kind of split
and again it's doing a random split so
that sounds pretty good to me
let's show some randomly chosen images
yeah so i guess they do set up the
training data here
and then down below we're actually
showing the images so here's some random
images
train on a remote cluster so for this
task you submit the job to run on the
remote training cluster to set up
earlier submit your job
uh create the directory create a
training script create a script for run
configuration submit the job so
first we will create our directory
and notice it created this directory
over here
because i guess it's going to put the
training file in there and so this will
actually write
to a training file this makes quite a
bit of sense
so if we click into here it should now
have a training file we'll just give it
a quick
read see what's going on here so a lot
of times when you create these training
files you have to do
and this is the same if you're using aws
like when you're creating trade like or
sagemaker
um you create a train file because it's
part of the frameworks it's just how the
frameworks work but you'll have
these arguments uh so it could be like
parameters to
run for training um and there could be a
whole sorts of ones here
here they're loading in the training and
testing data so it's the same stuff we
saw
earlier when we were just viewing the
data
here it's doing a logistic regression
it's using lib
uh so linear uh maybe a linear learning
model there
it's doing multi-class on that there and
so
what's going to do is fit so fit is
actually performing the training
and then what it's going to do is make a
prediction on the test set
uh then it's going we're going to get
accuracy so we're getting kind of a
score so notice that it's using
accuracy as a evaluation metric i
suppose
right and then at the end we're going to
dump the data a lot of times
like you have to save the model
somewhere so they're outputting the
actual
weights of the neural network and all
other stuff it's a plk file i don't know
what that is
but if you're using like tensorflow you
would use tensorflow serving at the end
of this
a lot of times uh frameworks will like
pi pi torch or tensorflow
or mxnet they'll have a serving layer um
but uh since we're just using
scikit-learn which is very simple
it's just going to dump out that file
into our outputs
this is going to probably run a
container so this outputs isn't going to
necessarily be on
the outputs into here it's more like the
outputs of the container
and a lot of times the container will
then
place this somewhere so like it'll be
saved on the container but it'll be
passed out to the register or
or something like that like model
registry so anyway we ran this
so that generated the file we don't want
to keep on running this multiple times i
probably just overwrite the files it's
not a big deal
here it says notice how the script gets
saved in the data model so here it's
saying the data
data folder i guess we didn't look at
that so we go top here
um i didn't see this is data folder
i wasn't really paying attention to
where that was because
it looks like where more so it's loading
the data in
so here it saves the data put anything
right into this directory it's
automatically uploaded to your workspace
so
i guess that's just how it works so it
probably will end up in here then
um so util pi referenced the training
script to load the data set correctly
and copy the file over
so um we will
run this to copy the file over
so i'm guessing did it put it into here
i'm just wondering yeah so just put it
in there because when
it actually uh packages it for the
container it's gonna bring that file
over because it's a dependency
so configure the training job so
create a script run config the directory
that contains the script the compute
target the training script
training file etc sometimes like in
other frameworks we'll just call them
estimators but here's just called a
script run config
so i'm just trying to see what it's
doing
so scikit-learn is the dependency okay
sure we'll just hit run
okay and then down below here we have
script
run config so
it looks like we're passing our argument
so we're saying this is our data folder
which is
apparently here we're mounting it and
then we're setting regularization to 0.5
sometimes you'll pass in dependencies in
here as well i guess these are
technically
our parameters that are getting
configured up here at the top
right but sometimes you'll have
dependencies if you're
including including other files here
and i guess that's up here right so see
where it says environment and then we're
saying
include the azure ml defaults and the
scikit learn
and stuff like that and so then it gets
passed in the env so that makes sense to
me
we haven't ran that yet because we don't
see any number here
submit the job to the clusters let's go
ahead and do that
it says it returns a preparing or
running state as soon as the job is
completed so it's in a starting state
monitor remote run so in total the the
first run takes 10 minutes but the
second run
is as long as the dependencies in azure
ml environment don't change the same
images reuse and hence the start
here start time is much faster here's
what's happening while you wait the
image creation a docker image is
is created matching the python
environment specified by the azure ml
environment
the image is built and stored in the
acro
the azure container registry associated
with your workspace let's go take a look
and see if that's the case
because sometimes like resources aren't
visible to you so i'm just curious
do we actually see it okay and yep there
it is
okay so they did not lie um
so associated workspace image creation
uploading takes about five minutes the
stage happens once
for each python environment since the
containers cache subsequent runs during
image creation
logs are stemmed to the run history you
can monitor the image creation
proc process using these logs wherever
those are
if you if the remote cluster requires
more nodes to execute the run than
currently available additional nodes are
added automatically scaling takes
typically takes about five minutes
and i've seen this before where if
you're in your compute here and
sometimes it'll just say like scaling
because it's just done enough
so uh running in the stage the necessary
scripts and files are sent to the
compute target then the data stores are
mounted copied the entry script is run
so entry script is actually the train
dot pi
file while the job is running sd out in
the files
is in the logs directory or stem to the
run history you can monitor the run's
progress using these
logs the dot outputs directory
of the run is copied over to the run
history in your workspace so you can
access these results
you can check the progress of a running
job in multiple ways this tutorial uses
the jupiter widget
so looks like we can run this watch the
progress
so maybe we'll run that and so it's
actually showing us the progress that's
kind of cool i really like that
so it's just a little widget showing us
all the things that it's doing
let's go take a look and see what we can
see under experiments and our run
pipeline
because i was talking about things like
outputs and things like that so over
here in the outputs and logs i'm just
curious
as if this is the same thing
i'm not sure if this uh is it this tails
yeah it does tail it just moves so we
can actually monitor it from here i
guess that's what it was talking about
um so here we can see that it's setting
up docker it's actually building a
docker image
and then i'm not sure
did it send it to i mean it's on acr
already i think
it looks like it's just still uh
downloading extracting packages so maybe
it's actually running on the image now
so we'll just wait there
we pop back over here you know we can
see probably the same information is
identical yeah it is
so we're three minutes in uh it's
probably not that fun to
to watch it in real time and and talk
about it so let's just wait until it's
done i'll see you back then okay
all right so i'm about 17 minutes in
here i'm not seeing any more
movement here so it could be that it is
done it does say if you run this next
step here it will wait for completion
um specify show output to true for
verbose log
so here actually it did output a moment
ago so maybe it actually was done
um i just ran it twice so i'm not sure
if that's going to
cause me uh issues there so
because i can't run the next step unless
i stop this um
can i individually cancel this one here
i think i can just hit interrupt the
kernel there we go
okay so i think that it's done okay
because it's 18 minutes
in and i don't see any more logging in
here it's just not very clear
and also uh the logs we just have a lot
of stuff going on here like
it's just so much so you know if we were
keeping keeping pace we probably just
would have saw all these credits yeah so
another
we just had a few more outputs there but
uh i think
that it's done okay
it's just there's nothing definitively
saying like done
do you know what i'm saying and then up
here it doesn't say oh oh i guess it
does say that it's done all right
so yeah i just never ran it with this
tool so i just don't know
so i guess it does definitively say that
i already ran this so we don't need to
run that again i just
feel like we'll get stuck there so let's
take a look at the metrics
so regularization rate is 0.5 accuracy
is
nine so nine is pretty good the last
step is train the script wrote in the
output s
s sklearn i want to see if it's actually
in
our environment here i don't think it is
so outputs is somewhere
it's in our workspace somewhere but it's
just not uh
we just don't oh it's right here okay so
it output the actual model right there
um and so
you can see the associated files that
are ran okay we'll run it
register the work model in space so you
can work with other collaborators sure
so if i click on that here and we go
back over to our models
it is now registered over here okay
and so we're done part one i don't want
to do all these other parts
training is enough as it is but let's
just take a look at the deploy stage
okay so for prerequisites
uh we're setting up a workspace we have
our we
are loading our registered model
okay we register it we have to import
packages
we are going to
[Music]
create scoring script deploy to an aci
model test the model
if you want to do this you can go
through all the steps it does talk about
confusion matrix and that is something
that
can show up on the exam is actually
talking about a confusion matrix but we
do cover that in lecture content so
you generally understand what that is
but um you know i'm just
i'm too tired i don't want to run
through all this there's not a whole lot
of value other than
reading reading through it yourself here
so i think we're all
done here okay
[Music]
okay one service we forgot to check out
was data labeling so let's go over there
and give that a go so i'm going to go
ahead and create ourselves a new project
i'm going to say
my labeling project and we can say
whether we want to
classify images or text we have
multi-class multi-label
bounding box segmentation let's go with
multi-class
i'll go back here for a second
multi-class whoops
i don't know if we uh create a data set
but we could probably upload some local
files
let's say uh my star trek data set
just let us choose the image file type
here be nice if these were images gonna
tell us what here
it's very finicky this input here file
this it references a single or multiple
files in your public data store or
private public url okay so go next
uh if we can upload files directly
that'd be nice ooh upload a folder i
like that
so what we'll do um is we do have some
images in the free
ai here under cognitive services assets
uh we have um we'll go back here
and we'll say
i think objects would be the easiest
oh but we just want a folder right so
yeah we'll just take objects
yep we'll upload the 17 files
uh yep we'll just let it stick to that
path that seems fine to me
we will go ahead and create it and so
now we have a data set there we'll go
ahead and select that data set we'll say
next your data set is periodically
checked for new data points any data
points will be added as tasks
it doesn't matter we're only doing this
for test uh enter the list of labels so
we have
um tng
ds9 voyager
toss that's the types of star trek
episodes
um label which
um star trek series
the image is from say next
i don't want enabled but you can have
auto enabled assistant labeler i'm going
to say no we'll create the project
okay and i'll just wait for that crate
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
all right so i'm back here actually
didn't have to wait long i think it
instantly runs i just assumed like i was
waiting for a state that says completed
but it's not something we have to do so
we have 0 out of 17
progress we're going to go in here we're
going to go label some data
we can view the instructions it's not
showing up here but that's fine if we go
to tasks
we can start labeling so what season is
this from or series this is voyager
we'll hit submit this is voyager we'll
hit submit
this is toss we'll hit submit this is
tng
this is tng this is ds9
ds9 voyager
voyager tng
ds9 you get the idea though you got some
options here like change the contrast if
someone can't see the photo or rotate it
this is voyager
voyager tng
ds9 um voyager
voyager and we're done so we'll go back
to our labeling job here
we'll see we have the breakdown there uh
and now our data set is
labeled we can export our data set csv
coco
azure ml data set i believe that means
it'll go back into
the data sets over here which will make
our lives a little bit easier
go back to data labeling okay
so you just granted people access to the
studio they'd be able to just go in here
and and jump into that job okay
if we go over to the data set i believe
we should have a labeled version of it
now so my labeling project
so i believe that is the uh the labeled
stuff here
right yep so it's labeled
so there you go we're all done as your
machine learning uh and so all that's
left is to do some cleanup
okay so we're all done with azure
machine learning uh if we want to we can
go to our compute
and just kill the services we have here
now if we go to the resource group and
delete everything it'll take all these
things down anyway but i'm just going to
go
a little bit paranoid so i'm going to
just manually do this okay
hit delete
okay and so we'll go back to
portal.azure.com
and i'm going to go to my resource
groups
and everything is contained it should be
all contained within my studio just be
sure to check these other ones for that
and we can see all the stuff that we
spun up we'll go ahead and hit delete
resource group
i don't know if it includes like because
i don't see like container registry
right
so i know like it put stuff there
i guess it does this is container
registry so that's pretty much
everything right
and that'll take down everything so and
if you're paranoid all you can do is go
to all resources and double check over
here because if there's anything running
it'll show up here okay
um but that's pretty much it and so just
delete and we're all done
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're onto the ai 900 cheat sheet
and this one is seven
pages long so let's get to it at the top
of our list we're starting with
artificial intelligence a machine that
can perform jobs that mimic human
behavior
machine learning a machine that gets
better at a task of explicit programming
deep learning a machine that has
artificial neural net inspired by the
human brain to solve complex problems
a data scientist is a person with
multi-disciplinary skills in math
statistics predictive modeling
machine learning to make future
predictions data set is a logical
grouping of units of data that are
closely related or share the same data
structure
examples of this would be mnis and coco
data labeling the process of identifying
raw data so images text files videos and
adding one or more meaningful
and informative labels to provide
context so a machine learning model can
learn
supervised learning data that has been
labeled for training
unsupervised learning data that has not
been labeled and the ml model needs to
do its own labeling
reinforcement learning so there is no
data and there's an environment and an
ml model generates today with many
attempts to reach a goal
you have neural networks also
abbreviated to nn a network of nodes
organized into layers so input hidden
output that is used to train ml models
we have deep neural nets so dnn a neural
net that has three or more hidden layers
consider deep learning back propagation
moves backwards through a neural net
adjusting weights to improve outcome on
the iteration
this is how a neural net learns loss
function a function that compares the
ground truth to the prediction to
determine the error rate
how bad the network performed activation
functions and algorithm apply to a
hidden layer
node that affects connected output so
rel use a very common one
you have a dense layer this is when the
next layer increases the amount of nodes
you have a sparse layer this is when the
next
layer decreases the amount of nodes you
have gpus that is specially designed to
quickly
render high resolution images and videos
concurrently commonly used for
non-graphical tasks such as machine
learning and scientific computing
you have cuda which is a parallel
computing platform an api by nvidia
that allows developers to use cuda
enabled gpus for general purpose
computing
also known as gpu gu
on to the second sheet here for ml
pipeline we have preprocessing
i didn't outline this in the course so
i'm going to just do that now
so preparing data and feature
engineering before passing data to the
ml model for training inference you
might have data cleaning so this is
correcting errors within the data set
that could negatively impact the results
data reduction reducing the amount of
data or applying
dimensionality reduction to reduce the
dimensions of inputed vectors
feature engineering transforming data
into numerical
vectors uh to be ingested by the ml
model
sampling or resampling balancing a
data set to be uniform across labels by
adding or removing records
post-processing translating the output
of an ml model back into human readable
format
training the process of training the
model serving the process of deploying
the model to an endpoint to be used for
inference
inference invoking an ml model by
sending a request and expecting backup
prediction
we have real-time endpoints so optimize
optimized for small or single
item payloads returns results quickly
usually uses a dedicated running server
batch transform optimized for larger
batch predictions server runs only
for the duration of the batch there's
forecasting make a prediction uh with
relevant data analysts of trends and
it's not guessing
predicting make a future prediction with
without relevant data using statistics
to
predict future outcomes more of guessing
using decision theory
for performance and evaluation metrics
are used to evaluate
different machine learning algorithms
just to
select a few here classification we have
accuracy f1 score precision recall
for regression metrics we have msc rmse
me remember mean squared uh errors okay
jupiter notebooks a web-based
application for authoring documents
combined live code narrative text
equations
visualizations classification is the
process of finding a function to divide
a label data set into classes and
categories
a confusion matrix is a table to
visualize the model prediction so
predicted versus ground truth actual
take the time to go look up how
confusion matrix
work because they will absolutely ask
you questions on the exam for the ai-900
okay
regression is the process of finding a
function to correlate a labeled data set
into continuous variable numbers
clustering is the process of grouping
unlabeled data based on similarity and
differences
okay on to our third sheet here
cognitive service is an umbrella ai
service that enables customers to access
multiple ai services with an api keen
endpoint
we have the category of decisions so
anomaly detector identify pro
potential problems early on content
moderator detect potential offensive
or unwarranted content personalizer
create
rich personalized experience for
everyone uh language understanding so
build natural language understanding
into the app spots and iot devices
q a maker create a conversational
question and answer
layer over the data text and analytics
detect sentiment key phrases and unnamed
entries
translator detect translate and more
than 90 supported languages
for speech we have speech to text
transcribe audible
speech into readable text text to speech
convert text to lifelike speeches for
more natural interfaces
speech translation integrate real time
speech translation of your apps
speak recognition identify verify the
people
speaking based on the audio for vision
we have computer vision so
analyze content and images and videos
custom vision customize
image recognition to fit your business
needs face detect the
uh detect and identify people and
emotions and images
knowledge mining is a discipline in ai
that uses a combination of intelligent
services to quickly learn
from vast amounts of information and
there's three things to this there's
ingest so content from a range of
sources using connectors
to first and and third-party data stores
enrich the content with the ai
capabilities that let you extract
information find patterns
deep understanding explore the newly
indexed data via search boxes
uh existing business applications and
data visualizations onto our fourth
sheet
we have microsoft ai principles so this
is responsible ai
remember there's six so fairness an ai
system should treat all people fairly
reliability and safety ai systems should
perform reliability and safety privacy
and security
ai systems should be secure respect
privacy inclusiveness ai systems should
empower everyone engaged people
transparency ai systems should be
understandable accountability people
should be accountable for the ai systems
common ml workloads so for this we have
anomaly detection
uh is the process of finding outliers uh
with a data set
called anomaly computer vision is when
we use ml neural nets to gain high
level understanding of digital images
and videos nlp is the
is the machine learning that can
understand the context of corpus or body
of text
conversational eye is technology that
can participate in conversations with
humans
i know it feels like we're repeating the
same thing in different ways but that's
the way we're going to learn well here
okay
azure machine learning service allows
you to provision an ml studio to build
and maintain ml models and pipelines
we have authors so under that we have
notebooks with jupy remote books and ide
to write
python code to build ml models remember
you can launch
it in jupiter labs and vs code as well
probably won't show up in the exam but
just so you know
auto mal completely automated process to
build and train an ml model
designer visual drag and drop designer
construct and ml pipelines
we have data sets so data that you can
upload which will be used for training
data can be versioned open data sets are
publicly hosted data sets that are
commonly used
for learning how to build ml models
experiments are
a logical grouping of runs runs are ml
tasks that perform on virtual machines
or containers pipelines so ml
workflows you have built or have used in
the designer
you have a training pipeline so
pipelines to build and train an ml model
inference pipelines pipelines that are
used to train
that use a trained model to make a
prediction on real data
then you have models this is a model
registry containing uh trained models
that can be deployed
endpoints when you deploy a model it's
hosting an accessible endpoint so rest
api so real-time endpoints invokes
volkswagen ml model for inference
pipeline endpoint
invokes the running on a pipeline so for
ci cd
under managed we have compute the
underlying computing instances used
for notebooks training inference so we
have compute instances
development workstations that data
scientists use to work with the data and
models this is generally for your
notebooks
computer clusters scalable clusters for
virtual machines on-demand processing
experimental code so training
and pre-processing inference clusters
deployment targets for predictive
services that use for trained models so
refer inference
attach compute links to existing azure
compute resources such as
virtual machines azure data bricks
clusters and there's another one in
there but it's not going to show up in
the exam probably apache spark but i
guess it's covered under data bricks
so for environments a reproduce
reproducible python environment for
machine learning experts or uh
experiments data stores uh securely
connect to your
storage service on azure without putting
uh your authentication credentials in so
it has blob storage file share data
data like storage gen 2 azure sql data
azure postgres mysql database data
labeling have humans and ml assisted
labeling to
label your data for supervised learning
human and loop labeling machine learning
system
data labeling we have linked services so
external services that
you can connect to the workspace such as
azure synapse analytics i think that's
the only one you can connect right now
then for text analytics so now we're out
of
um the azure machine learning services
and we're interested in the cognitive
services so text analytics
sentiment analysis find out what people
think of your brand or topic
labels include negative positive mixed
or neutral confidence scores ranging
from zero to one
opinion mining granular information
about the opinions related to aspects
granular data with a subject and opinion
tied to a sentiment
key phrase extraction quickly identifies
the main concepts and texts
language detection detects the language
in an input text is
written in named entity recognition and
er detects words and phrases mentioned
in unstructured texts
that can be associated with one or more
sentiment types
we have lewis or luis language
understanding
a no code ml service to build natural
language into app spots and iot devices
it uses nlu the ability to transform a
linguistic statement to a representative
that
enables you to understand your users
naturally luis key schema component so
we have intentions the user
what the user is asking for so a lewis
app contains
a non-intent entities what parts of the
entity
intent is used to determine the answer
utterances examples of the user input
that
includes intent and entities to train
the ml model to match predictions
against the real user input
for q a maker generate a bot from a url
pdf
and uh it's supposed to be docx
for docs that's a spelling mistake think
of a docx file
multi-term conversation so follow-up
prompts to narrow a specific answer
chit chat personalized can responses for
azure bot service allow you to host bots
so you have the bot framework sdk which
is an end to end sdk to build test
publish connect
evaluate bots that's the entire uh
pipeline that they described
bot framework composer a desktop
application to uh design bots leverage
the
bot framework sdk so there you go that's
the whole cheat sheet
uh usually i would break it up for
service but there's a lot of intermixing
so that's why i did it this way but
you know good luck on your exam and i
hope you pass